good morning everyone um the chairman is
running a few minutes
late um so he asked me will'll
officially open up our
meeting
um for the morning and uh and then we're
going to recess and have uh caucus and
then
resume when he arrives expected well
there's a few I'm sure I'm sure we could
mean y as much as that would be
um so uh representative gagy if you
Allegiance
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all did he give it time he said he said
minutes all right so uh we'll now be in
recess and um resume again at 10
a.m. not
think
thank you very much I apologize folks
today is my daughter's 25th birthday
she's a Valentine's Day baby she asked
me to speak at her school this morning
so I did and then I had to come here as
quickly as I can so I
apologize um for keeping everyone late
um representative kahill one father to
another you did the right thing Mr
chairman thank you so again I apologize
for being late we have some bills to
deal with today we also have the
Department of Labor um here uh excuse me
Employment Securities here uh because I
think before we make some votes and and
some strategy and some other things uh
representative McKenzie's bill um is is
complex and it needs some explanation
and and I think it was is appropriate
for us to at least understand a little
bit from what I
presented um uh that I the emails I sent
you uh representative Sullivan and I
will kind
of go through this as best we can all
this you have one I it's probably in
this mess I I'll organize myself so
we're opening the hearing at at uh
executive session at 10:05 house bill um
1178 representative
alalani
[Music]
yes you were you were you were may I
um are you the chair I am I'm going to
retract that representative avalani for
a moment please rep representative
kahill you're recognized for a motion
thank you Mr chair um I would like to
move Amendment
which uh addresses a few of the concerns
that were expressed at the hearing and
Beyond um we've done everything possible
okay well you you have a motion uh yes
yes uh a
second Sullivan you recognize to speak
to your motion go ahead representative
kale thank you Mr chair uh the the bill
as was intended uh applies only to
employers of 15 more
employees uh it does require them to
inform the employee of uh policies
regarding acral or unused time and
limits so this is good this is a good
business sense that's has been described
to me providing means uh where the
requests and approvals are process
further good business sense and PR
practice uh providing employees with
accounting of earned time and un use
time remaining again consistent with
normal business practices and
and
um what we're doing here is we're saying
if the employee is is separated from un
from
employment uh not fired but separated uh
the business closes the ownership
changes it's a seasonal employment with
no reasonable Assurance of the employee
being able to return to work Mr Abbott
you're welcome uh then the unused paid
time such as vacation will will be paid
but not sick days because we don't want
you to get sick and if you know you
don't get sick but your unused vacation
time would be paid and for employers
that don't delineate the types of paid
off they just have PTO all One bank they
said it's all One bank then it stays all
One Bank uh with the exception of sick
if they don't if they want to parse it
out somehow and this would be paid uh to
the employee which as we we know is
common practice but in in New Hampshire
and many other states it's not required
but this would require it in the
conditions where the person through no
fault to their own P the employment ends
uh there's no not for cause but the
employment just ends uh and that's the
chairman thank you Mr chairman
um can I ask the sponsor a
question yes
um under
onea or in time shall be paid in a
pro-rated basis is that prated how well
prated as in uh the person the the
person has worked for six months and
then the the job ends so any
unused would be would be like divided by
example so you don't get all you don't
get everything that was promised to you
on day one or given to you on day one
you get appropriate to the time of the
amount of time that's passed since the
when the employment
ends and a followup question what if the
employer wanted to pay all of it uh
there's nothing that would prevent them
from doing that this is only what they
would be required to do it's a shall be
paid on a prated basis that's why I'm
just
checking um yes the the shell is so that
they will and anyone who wants to give
penalty thank you thank you Mr
chairman representative K Hill you and I
have oh I'm sorry representative
proud um thank you Mr chair um so my
concern uh with this bill is that
appears to be retroactive to vacation
time earned before the effective day of
the bill um this will companies to make
changes in that 59 days before it
becomes effective and uh address the new
liability that's coming their way um
because the value of the full unused
balance of the vacation time of all
employees will suddenly show up on their
accounting sheets on their balance sheet
Um this can affect the company's credit
rating their ability to get a bank loan
and other issues uh I'd be much more
open to this topic if it only affected
time earned after the effective date of
this bill um but as written applying to
the full outstanding balance of uh the
vacation time as of the effective of the
law I can't support it well thank you Mr
Prout uh I suppose that that could be uh
examined in the other
chamber uh but I I don't think it's a
significant problem for the you know for
the number of employees and the
likelihood that there that there's going
to be a layoff or you know of this of
this magnitude uh and I think uh it's a
reasonable very reasonable measured bill
and if uh if you like to uh join me in
the senate for the hearing and offer
that suggestion I'm sure they would take
consideration anyone
else representive kahill you and I have
been worked on this a number of times
and and I must apologize to you because
I have been so busy uh with all the
other bills we've had in front of this I
have not done um the due diligence and
worked with you as I had hoped on this I
like l lines four and five I like lines
um
and the request I had made to uh to
legislative Services was just
that um I didn't get it done on time I
haven't had an opportunity to speak with
you and you have tried numerous times to
talk with me no doubt and all I can say
is I apologize again there just too many
other spreadsheets and other things that
I've been trying to take care of for
this committee um I am going to vote
against this and I will tell you what
I'm another thing I'm going to do with
representative
McKenzie if you and I can agree on the
amendment which I'm waiting for
legislative Services I'm happy to bring
that that out as a floor Amendment and
support it if you and I agree on the
house floor before we have crossover or
even before next week um but with some
of the things that are in here I'm I'm
still wishy-washy on the seasonal and I
I don't like lines 13 and
um but I i' I've given you I've told you
a number of times I would support an
employee separate SE ated from
employment uh because the business
closed change owner and changed
ownership which is what I'm willing to
do um but I I again I I should have had
this I I wanted to have this
conversation with you over the telephone
or in person I'm sorry to do it here um
this is as close as it's it's come to
being something I think but I don't
think that your comments to
representative Prout about trying to
deal with this in the Senate um last
year uh when the bill passed the house
it went over to the Senate and and it
didn't really get uh its
due it got you
know no disrespect to you they got beat
up uh and I want to make something
that's going to that I I believe will
pass the Senate so I'm just letting you
know ahead of time what my plan is um
and unfortunately why I can't support
your Amendment all right uh thank you Mr
chairman I as as you as you well know I
I have been diligent in trying to get
this to going and and talk with you and
sent uh word smithing to Mr alalani and
reached out to the committee uh tried to
accommodate Mr Abbott's concerns with
the seasonal business uh you know
threading the needle with uh it's
challenging and
uh uh I I agree that it could use a bit
more work but I I haven't seen what it
is that you're trying to get from OS I
want to go forward with this and it
could be amended perhaps to our
agreement agement with a floor Amendment
so uh uh I'm asking the members to
support this because it's a it's a it's
the right thing to do it's a positive
step and we'll see what we can figure
out when it comes to the before it comes
to the floor we'll have to make an
discussion repres
suiv um I just want to offer my support
for the uh for the process um
representative kahill is uh worked in
this for a long time he's bent over
backwards trying to um satisfy the
concerns of lots of people um and I am
going to vote in favor of it um I'm
going to encourage um my colleagues on
the committee here to V vote in favor
and if there's a uh uh amendment that
would uh uh further improve the bill on
the floor um uh once we we've seen that
um it may very well um have my support
as well but not having seen it I can't
say that now thank you
on Amendment 202
40652 I seeing no other
um a debate Madam clerk would you please
call the
role Vice chair seaworth
no rep alalani no
rep Prout no rep love no rep Boyd no rep
gagy no rep KC no rep Drago no rep
Granger no ranking Dem Sullivan yes rep
Rudy yes rep Cahill yes rep haken hackin
Phillips yes rep Susi yes
rep rard yes rep McKenzie yes the clerk
votes yes rep cair yes rep stab yes Mr
chair no 10 to
10 motion fails is up for further
Amendment representative kill no that's
a different one sorry I saw your other
Amendment
here
um K
Hill uh thank you chair like to move a
to pass motion on the floor is ought to
pass is seconded by representative stab
you recognized to speak to your
motion yes as we've discussed the uh
this has been a long process and there
may be Improvement that can be made uh
with uh chair and other others meeting
to discuss the concerns about it uh hope
to do that uh sooner than later so that
this can go to the floor and go to the
other body uh so I'm voting on to pass
and urge the others to do the same it's
speak motion on the floor is ought to
pass on House Bill 17
1178 it's been moved in second we've had
discussion Madam clerk would you please
call the
role Vice here seaworth no rep avalani
no rep Prout no rep love no rep Boyd no
rep gagy no rep kcam no rep Drago no rep
Greer no ranking Dam Sullivan yes rep
barudi yes rep Cahill
yes RIP hackin Phillips yes rep Susi yes
rep buard yes rep McKenzie yes the clerk
votes yes repair yes rep stab yes Mr
chair no 10 to
10 motion fails is open to
further uh motion represent aling uh
thank you Mr chairman I move
itl motion the floor is itl moved byes
aani second by representative Prout
representative alalani your Mo uh
recognized to speak to your
thank you Mr chairman in light of all
the discussion here today
um the bill and Amendment still in
interjects the state in between and
defines um certain policies and
procedures for paying out
um
certain benefits as um
wages um in part two as well um
also sick time and sick dat days
um
it pulls out you know if somebody just
says PTO it also differentiates between
sick time and sick days and um I hope
that we can come to an agreement between
representative kale and the chair to um
clean up the language um so we can have
Amendment again I will apologize to my
um colleague he has uh attempted a
numerous times in emails and phone calls
and seeing me in person and and I I
apologize for not being able to get uh
the amendment I'd like to see in
everyone's hands um and in your hands um
I say that with all sincerity Michael um
I do want to resolve this I do want to
get this done with the things that we
agreed on uh I will voting be voting itl
but I will U continue to work with
representative kale so uh possibly we
can agree to an amendment both sides
that we all agree on uh that can be on
the floor in the next two
weeks seeing no other uh comments
represent excuse me
y Madam clerk so is it avalani proud or
please motion on itl Vice chair seaworth
yes rep avalani yes rep Prout yes rep
love yes rep Boyd yes rep gagy yes rep
kcom yes rep drgo yes rep Greener yes
ranking D Sullivan no rep Rudy no rep
kahill no rep hackin Phillips no rep
Susi no rep brushard no rep McKenzie no
the clerk votes no rep clear no rep stub
no Mr chair yes 10 to
10 okay I a um I need the blurs um in
the hand of of our assistant by 3:00
today yes please uh I'll be here I'll
stay here uh because I know
representative berui and representative
proud have dates this afternoon
uh on Valentine's Day so we're going to
be out of here by 1:00 so they can do
their
business okay you have a date this
afternoon as well okay all of you be
sweethearts next bill in front
representative kale I just wanted to
interject to people who saying they have
dates to their spouse K watch kets on
I would hope you would find better
sweethearts House Bill
1377 FN relative to granting free choice
for workers representative Sullivan you
recognized for a motion I move ought to
you motion on the floor is inexpedient
to legislate um seconded by
representative
Susi salivan you're you're recognized
for your
motion we've been around this uh Bush
quite a few times um right to work has
always been bad for New Hampshire um it
continues to be bad for new Hampshire um
and and frankly um it's especially bad
in the year when um unions are coming
back strong um I mean tell the UPS uh
workers that this is a good idea tell
the um UAW workers this is a good idea
um unions are coming back this bill is
designed to weaken unions and uh nothing
uh should be further from our minds in a
year like this um so I strongly oppose
um this bill and I urge everyone else to
do the same thank you thank you
representative
Granger thank you Mr chair um this this
year is going to be like many prior
years and uh 2023 has shown that it was
once again the lowest rate of union
membership in recorded memory and that's
been the case basically every year for
close to 40 years now um we could talk
about how I I believe that I believe
this is going to come back whether it
passes this year or not every two years
until it either passes or it becomes
irrelevant because nobody's in a union
anymore and that seems to be the way
that it's trending and I don't want to
interrupt anybody if who wants to be in
a union um but the I don't think that
independent workers should be held
hostage uh in order give unions more
negotiating power uh being an
independent worker supporting
independent workers is important to me
therefore I will oppose the itl
motion representative Susi thank you Mr
chairman I look at it a different
way the bill comes to us I've been here
14 years it's been here we've defeated
it so last year when the bill came we it
was coming before us we got an email
plus we got letters from National right
to work so I decided that I'm going to
take one of those letters and I'm going
to send an email because when I saw that
they said 80% of New Hampshire people
support right to work I did my own study
I went out I saw about a 100 people and
I asked them if they knew what right to
work
was and I can almost guarantee that 60%
of them said everybody should have the
right to work everybody should have the
right to work and we all believe that so
it was false avat ment on the national
Right to Work Foundation to come out
here put a letter out to Democrats send
it to my house but I did a study that's
the first thing secondly if you look
around this room we have businesses here
now some people say may say that unions
are not business however they are
associations and I brought this up three
years ago when we defeated right to
work I believe that any individual that
represents another member should get
paid they should get paid we have
lobbyists here that have many clients
they have members they can charge their
members fees dues whatever they get paid
people will say well they don't have to
join pretty simple you don't have to
join a union either so we're going to
sit here we're going to discriminate
against a private company because they
have a union logo and say oh you're the
only ones that can't charge your members
fees to represent you we're
sorry I don't believe that's an a hemp
way honestly let's look at it that way
it's a business perspective and again
Mike's last bill and I talked to Brian
about this I don't believe we interfere
in businesses I don't believe we stick
our nose in
there I'd like to see this bill get
defeated because I think once again
we're getting involved in private
businesses where we've heard this if the
company's Union you don't want to work
there you don't want to work for a union
there's other employment and I hate to
say it that way but there is other
employment so I don't support right to
chairman representative
love thank you Mr chair thank you
members uh I've got a lot of personal
experience with uh with unions good and
bad uh and uh I was St I was brought up
in a union household my my grandfather
was a a charta member of Teamster's
Local 25 uh his name is on the chart uh
my father was a lifelong Teamster my
mother's a past president of one of the
ibw locals in in uh in Massachusetts um
in 1974 I got a a job that was a
Teamsters Union uh represent it had
Teamsters Union representation and uh
the business agent literally went out to
went out to dinner went out to lunch
with the bosses three times a week uh
came back very inebriated I don't know
what went on or anything else but
whenever we needed him he wasn't there
and it would have been real nice to say
hey uh Mr O you know no more you're not
getting another nickel for me till you
start doing your job I'd be fired if I
didn't do mine and he should have been
fed but there was no means of doing that
uh not not any means that we could uh
you know uh muster enough to enough
votes for but uh you know the fact of
the matter is uh he wasn't representing
us um I've also worked in in a non-union
shop where four people were killed and
uh we were running you know 80 90 hours
a week and if there was a a a union it
was Union representation there uh any
business agent worth of salt would have
said hey put another butt in that seat
you know and and and and knock this off
uh the the man that uh was driving the
truck when the four people were killed
had 95 hours under his belt you know
that week um so so I do have and and one
other thing I I helped organize um a a
school bus company
I ended up getting fired for it but uh
you know once again safety issues is
what uh was what uh what had me doing
that on the other hand uh I'm I'm a a
freedom and liberty guy uh I don't
believe we should be forcing anybody to
buy a product Union representation and
all the benefits that go with it if they
don't want to uh you know uh
representative Susi mentioned uh you
know the the uh the fact that unions
have to represent that's that's a
federal issue you know Federal label law
let's call our federal delegation and
let's have them have them straighten it
out uh as far as the state of New
Hampshire goes uh we should not be
forcing people to buy something that
they don't want I can't you can't force
me to go buy a car I don't want or a
refrigerator that I don't want um why
should I have to buy a Buy Union
representation if I don't want it and
that that's where the line is drawn for
me you know it's a freedom and liberty
thing you know that's it
thanks
um thank you Mr chair uh I feel that
this
legislation is a state government
interference in businesses and unfair
for non-un employees to acquire the
benefits of a collective bargaining
agreement without contributing to the
cost while their fellow employees who
belong to the union support that
collective bargaining agreement with
their union
dues the federal government already
protects workers Freedom not to join a
union workers can opt out of membership
at a unionized
workplace and pay a reduced fee an
agency fee agency fee that covers the
Union's cost to negotiate for raises
benefits and to represent employers
employees if they have grievances at
work workers living in states that have
laws like this piece of legislation earn
a about $1,500 less per year than
workers in states without these laws the
wage penalty is even higher for women
and workers of color according to the
data from the Bureau of Labor Statistics
the rate of workplace deaths in higher
is higher in States than have that have
similar laws like this no empirical data
has been peer reviewed showing states
with right to work laws have attracted
businesses exclusiv exclusively because
of this law thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative
barudi uh thank you Mr Mr
chairman uh this is the 19th time that
I've seen this legislation um and fought
against the uh fought against this
legislation but I can tell you this that
the presentations that were
made uh during the two days that we had
uh hearings here were
compelling they were people whose lives
were altered and changed and
improved by the union representation and
no disrespect to my
colleague uh there are outliers and I
understand that but for the most part
the people came here said look at my
life is better my family's life is
better we've done a good job uh
protecting uh protecting our our our job
and our families and that's compelling
stuff on the other hand we heard from
pres presentations from people from I
think was the associated general
contractors and also the right to work
and in both cases they made accusations
um and represented certain things before
this committee uh one of which was a
expression uh in their uh in their
statement about all the violence and all
of the coercion and all of those things
and as you might recall I asked them to
provide some evidence to support the
statement that they made publicly before
this committee and I've received nothing
in terms of the right to work committee
who quoted a contract provision from the
United Auto Workers and I asked them to
provide evidence to show this committee
that in fact that was true because they
were they were quoting something which
was illegal under the federal law
compelling people to join the union and
denying them the opportunity to work in
a plan which is illegal you cannot deny
somebody the right to work in a in any
job you cannot fire them because they
don't want to be part of of the Union
they have the right to make that
decision that has already been decided
by by the federal
courts so this has come up over and over
again and it's a people say it's about
Freedom well let me say that for those
of us who are in unions and I've been a
member of the fir figh Union for 50
years um it's my freedom it I had the
freedom to be a member of the uh local
856 for the past 50 years it was a
wonderful and continuous to be a
wonderful experience and I think many of
the people who who are came to testify
had the same had the same uh
thing this is not necessary and I have
done this 19 times now as a president of
the AFL CIO I I fought against this
through every Administration over the
past 19 uh years and it's the same old
tired story it's the same old tired
story with a couple of different twist
nobody's being compelled or forced to be
in a union nobody that's not it's
illegal to do that you can work anywhere
you want to work now you may make a
decision that you don't uh you don't
want to work there because it is a union
environment but nobody's being forced in
or denied employment
opportunities and let me finally say
this when I questioned one of the
witnesses
about uh about the benefits it was a
former police officer and teacher who
did not want to be part of the
union and I understand that but I also
asked her um what happened when the
contract was
negotiated and the people in that Local
Union paid people to come in and
negotiate that collective bargaining
agreement I I asked I said did you take
the
benefits that were negotiated by
somebody that you had that you made no
contribution to whatsoever now the the
Union's not going to the unions can't
complain about that that's Our
obligation but they took it they took
that money and they took the benefits as
they continue to do and contribute
nothing to to uh to uh making that
happen and I think that that's an
inequity and I think that's unfair to
the people who are who are part of the
union and finally let me say this is
this is an initiative of the right to
work committee
nationally and what their initiative is
and what their goal is is to weaken the
labor movement it has been that way for
all the years that I've been doing this
if we can figure out says the right to
work some way of putting a wedge into
the workplaces of this country if we can
end up with people who who uh who don't
want to be in the union you end up with
a situation where you weaken the union
and you weaken the union so it's no
longer effective now I don't think
that's what the federal law says you
have the right to organize you have the
right to to freely join unions but the
right to but the the initiative of the
right to work is to weaken us and
destroy the labor movement in this
country and so Mr chairman I strongly
oppose uh this legislation as I have for
many many years and I joined with
hundreds of State reps both Democrat and
Republican who over this 19 years 19
times that I've been doing this have
said no to the right to work over and
over and over again enough is enough we
have big problems that we need to face
in the state and the fact that we're
spending our time sitting here today
dealing with an issue that has been
rejected over and over and over again by
the state legislature I think is UN is
unfair and I don't think it's
appropriate for for this so I hope these
members of this committee say no that's
enough thank you Mr chairman R broody
Follow by love thank you Mr chairman I
came here today knowing I wasn't going
to say a word but somebody hit the wrong
button on me when um they said that um
mentioned false
advertising well I got a couple things
that personally happened to
me I grew up across the street from a a
family of which um with five kids
I was in Hanford Supermarket one day and
there the youngest of them all a single
mother working three jobs to support her
son and to buy him those expensive
sneakers like all the other kids she she
didn't have a
dime and I had never had a conversation
with this young lady but she approached
me in the store with a big smile and
said Mr buuy um I was thinking of you
the other day she said I gave those
working people some money I didn't have
a lot of money I only sent them
$20 and I said what working people she
said the ones that make it right for
everybody to work I said the right to
work committee and she said
yes it was a dagger in my heart this
young girl was taken advantage of by
false
advertising she didn't have the $20 to
give but she gave it because of me she
said it you're the labor guy and I was
it and another person approached me a
former uh girlfriend's brother who sells
wigs chewed me out one day for voting
against right to work he said why would
you do that you're supposed to be a
labor guy I said I am I said do you know
what the right to work
was and well he wound up sending them
$100 and when I explained what the right
to work all did he was mad at himself
instead of
me and on another note I fought as many
battles as brother
McKenzie and um after the big telephone
Strike Back In the late
90s uh which cost billions of dollars at
the time we had this come up the very
next year Well less than a year later
the president of the local I think AT&T
or whatever showed up to vote against it
to ask us to vote against it and I asked
them why I said after a very bitter
strike which cost your company a lot of
money why would you come to defend this
uh to ask us to vote against this bill
he said it's
fairness he says we'll we'll fight it
out over the table but I think the fair
thing to do is to let the unions
organize and elect D and that's after a
guy who just got beat up for a four or
five month
strike so between the false advertising
and large companies really want
organized people they don't want an HR
department with 50 people because
everybody in the plant's coming up
looking for their own raise or their own
benefits you get a master contract
everybody lives under it and they don't
have to negotiate with every Union every
person in their building thank you Mr
Speaker and I know I'm not changing
anybody's mind but um he made me do it
by saying fairness I mean uh false
advertising thank you for your comments
representative
love thank you Mr chair uh as I read
this bill uh there's nothing in it that
prohibits anybody from joining a
union okay um if a
union has a good product they represent
the people uh they negotiate Fair
contract s they have good benefits uh
you be you damn right I'm going to join
that Union if if I have a chance okay uh
if they if they don't as I explained
earlier um you know I um I want to be
able to say
no uh it's it's as simple as that okay
um if I'm if I'm working in a a union a
union shop and uh you know let's face
itot some people get intimidated we've
talked about intimidation and stuff like
that uh
sometimes those votes don't go the way
they really really should because of
intimidation uh you know when I was
helping to organize that that bus
company I there was a few people that
tried to intimidate me I laughed at them
you know I don't intimidate easy but um
you know it does happen uh but like I
said you know the choice to join or not
join if uh
if General Motors is selling a good
pickup truck it's lasting you know
200,000 miles do you want want to be
forced into buying a a Ram pickup that
only has 100 it's only good for 120 it's
the same thing give give the workers
their choice and as far as um the um the
the people uh that are uh just taking
the Free Ride that's Federal that's
federal law um you know if if that's
your your your problem contact Maggie
Hassen and and jeene Shaheen you know um
I I don't think anybody should get a
free ride like that either I shouldn't I
shouldn't get get benefits I can't I
can't uh go to a health insurance
company and say hey I'm sick pay for my
my medical bills without paying in okay
the same thing should be going on in
labor I agree with that okay
wholeheartedly uh you know there's uh
there's people that fought and died for
those those rights and stuff absolutely
you know um you know you you should have
to
pay the problem I as I understand it is
exclusive rights bargaining
Clauses okay um if if I don't want to if
I don't want to join a union and and I'm
doing like representative barui said and
I'd have the right to do it to go
negotiate my own salary my own benefits
and all that um you know it it can make
a mess but uh you know if if I end up
better than the union you know than the
Union contract boy that the people be
screaming you know uh unions want
exclusive rights okay um I shouldn't I
shouldn't be held you know uh held to to
join a an organization that I don't want
to belong to it's just simple as that um
you know I should have that choice no M
and you know I I was impressed with all
the all the benefits and as a matter of
you know I'm a I'm on I've got a a
withdrawal card from uh from Teamster's
Local 633 sitting in my Bureau at home
okay if I got a job that was Union I'd
go back to absolutely 633 treated me
very well you know the other local there
down in L uh didn't treat me so well but
I should have that that opportunity to
just say no you know no no you're not
doing your job and uh and that that's
what this is about for me you know the
the ability to say no I don't want
it that's it thanks thank you
representative love um representative
Schultz followed by
llar thank you Mr chair as the
granddaughter of a Teamster and a
paramutual clerk Union member both my
grandfathers um the daughter of um
machinist and before that a Teamster um
um many uncles and Aunt my sister-in-law
my brother my spouse his father so many
Union logos on my family tree I would
not be here today with a degree from
American University and all the all the
strength the union gave my family as the
daughter of a of a guy who had a ninth
grade
education um if it weren't for the union
and I would say if you believe in
freedom and the ability for businesses
to negotiate with their members if you
value your union
card uh in private employment you should
oppose this bill um everything
that um well I could say a lot more I
think I'll just leave it at that but I
just feel hearing that someone was happy
to have a Teamster
card that that view should correlate
with opposing this bill um I know this
because I've lived it I also have worked
for labor unions myself including the
international AFL CIO and
DC
um it's made for a stronger economy and
a stronger workplace when unions Thrive
I'll leave it at that thank you repres
Clair Follow by stop thank you Mr chair
first off sorry rep rep love for all the
dismay that you've had to face in the
past it sounds like you'd probably still
be a member if that one person didn't
put a bad taste in your mouth which like
representative McKenzie said I mean
we're all far from perfect you know so
there are some bad seeds everywhere you
go and I agree with that um one thing I
don't necessarily agree with what
representative Granger said about
the are unions still
relevant if they weren't why are we
trying so hard to get get rid of them
that's my question um and that's all
this is trying to do is is undermine and
make them weaker um and much to the
points of other Representatives this is
this has been going on for I don't know
50 years 40 50 years in New Hampshire
and we're going to probably itl bills
that have only been out for a couple of
months I don't understand why this one
keep coming up after so many years and
knockdowns after so many years if we
really don't
want bills that are irrelevant to happen
then why vote in favor of this one um
also
um I'm sorry I lost my Chain of Thought
but um for now that's that's all thank
you Mr chair welcome representative
stab thank you Mr chairman um I just
would like to uh speak as the as a
consumer um I own a very old house and I
frequently need Carpenters I frequently
need electrici electricians and I
frequently need plumbers um and um we
recently had a big uh project on our
house we had to rebuild a porch and the
two gentlemen uh who did it said well
this is our last job we're going to
retire and we can't find young people to
take our place and um you know there's
we've heard a lot of um um of people
talking about how we need to get more
people in the trades you know you don't
need a college degree um as I was
listening to the testimony I my ears
would perk up every time they talked
about how they were training
electricians how they were training uh
uh carpenters and um and other trades
people and I think that you know while
we're trying to get more people into the
trades and it's the unions that are um
big players in making that happen
so that these people can can get into
these fields and have a satisfying life
and make a decent living I think this is
probably the last time uh last time that
we would want to be undermining them and
preventing them from um helping to
create the next generation of traits
people so um I will be um um I I am
going to be voting against this bill and
in favor of it Ling it because yeah we
don't need this thank you thank you
representative kahill
thank you Mr chair as as you know I've
had some trouble getting an electrician
come to my house and fix a couple of
things and my wife in her wisdom told me
not to touch it so we we do need to
wait uh I was on the phone just
yesterday with a member of the ibw the
business manager because I was asking
about the uh if he if they have any
experience with people coming out of the
job course Center in Manchester because
they have an electrical electrical
program and he told me that they they
have in the past but basically most of
the people that are there are from out
of state they're from North Carolina
Virginia and they come up there because
you the little way income they can get
the training and he'd like to get more
people from here who he can take to the
next level with the with the training
that the ibw provides and stay here and
work here and maybe come and fix those
problems at my house and maybe yours but
uh we're not getting enough people
interested in the trades uh they're
they're they're just not doing it so I I
certainly uh can empathize with what uh
my colleague said about the the dir of
people going into being able to to fix
things and the need for able you know
construction we need to build housing
well you need all those trees people to
do it so I I don't want to discourage
union membership I want I don't want to
I want to encourage people to work in
the trades and since the unions are are
pretty busy training people uh and and
make these making these careers
worthwhile through the union
negotiations and the benefits the
benefits that I think Mr love and I
agree people should pay for if they get
them uh then I'm going to I'm going to
oppose this bill as I've done every
other I mean I'm I'm not now and have
never been a union member but I would if
i' had the opportunity and uh there we
are thank you representative uh
Kum thank you Mr
chair I don't disag agree with with the
comments made with regard to if you want
to be part of a union you should pay the
dues um I'm not for getting free
services in that
aspect Still Remains a federal issue
that needs to be corrected and that's
our job to go to the federal government
this here often the comment is if you
don't want to work there go if you don't
want to be part of a union go find
another job I spent 25 years of my
career working for HVAC plumbers
electricians Sheet Metal Workers Pipe
Fitters all typically union jobs it's a
merit shop that we worked for and we had
over 200 Tradesmen working in the field
and very often the union tried to come
into our company they would send their
employees into our company and they
would
salt and we had one time when we
actually had to deal with an
organization vote and everything else it
didn't pass but going to this if you
don't want to work for a union go find
another job what happens in our case we
were all very happy working for a merit
shop we were treated very well we were
able to speak for ourselves and
negotiate our own pay rates we were
given great benefits um it was a
wonderful work environment with plenty
of training uh even a benefit of getting
paid uh reimbursement for college so had
we organized had that succeeded why
should I go look for another job I was
happy where I was the union sent in the
people to to send false advertising to
our employees about what they could get
at a union not necessarily what they
were going to get so the rules changed
you know I didn't I shouldn't have had
to go look for another job I was happy
the company was treating me well most of
our technicians felt the same I guess
which is why it didn't pass so there's
another side to the T table and you know
they looked at us because we had a large
base it would have been a great
membership ad to their Union I
understand that don't disagree but um at
that point in time if people wanted to
join the union there were plenty of
other Union companies that they could
have gone to with their trades
so it's both sides I will be voting to
support this and um I believe
wholeheartedly that
unions have a place with some people and
they definitely serve their purpose and
it's not a one-size fits-all and people
should have a right to choose um The
Dilemma that we have with the way the
federal government has written that law
is right now out of our hands but
you I
um you there was plenty of uh comments
made by many of the presenters
that a number of people on this table
around this table asked for the for the
backup uh for the com you know for
comments that were made that were not
provided but uh I
do think that the comments made by a
vast majority of the presenters on both
days were uh professional and courteous
uh to this committee and I applaud them
all uh for that I see no further hand uh
representative McKenzie
um Mr
J just for
clarification um under the under the
federal law uh the right to work which
is uh under the tapped hotley law is is
14b that was written in to give States
the authority to do this so when we say
it's a federal issue it's not a federal
issue under the current tapal laws 14b
says that states can do this
individually and the other thing I I
just if if this is a h word um nobody is
forced to join a union in this country
nobody can be forced to join a union if
you if there's a union shop and you want
to participate you can do that now the
question here is about Union security
this is the union security agreements
which is the core of the right to work
argument so whether or not you be can be
uh whether or not they can negotiate
Provisions that require that you pay a
certain percentage and it's not dues
it's a fee uh to support the activities
of the of the uh of the Union who is
negotiating on your behalf but nobody
can be compelled nobody can be fired in
this country for not join the union that
is a federal law and so I just want to
make sure that that we first of all
understand this is State jurisdiction
14b gives the states the
jurisdiction and uh and this is really
about Union security and finally nobody
can be forced to join any Union that
they they want to join no matter if if
the union is in place whatever the case
may be the only thing they can be can do
if it's negotiated and agreed to by both
the employer and the employees is to put
a uh unit security agreement in which is
what this law would
ban that's that's core of this uh of the
right to work thank you Mr
chairman all right I don't want to get
too out of control but representative
lir love kill keep to the point don't
repeat things you've already said please
yeah thank you Mr chair I kind of after
listen to rep kokum I remember what I
was going to say
um she's absolutely right you know
companies do offer great benefits and
and you you can definitely go work
wherever you want I agree with that 100%
but again uh relevance of unions if they
weren't around then companies would
have I guess or or employees would have
nothing
to um to look at say for instance um if
the if the unions went around didn't
offer their benefits then I don't think
anyone would and that's some of the
protections because I've talked I was I
was uh for five years I was like rep uh
McKenzie and I represented the
Carpenters Union 2,000 or so members in
New Hampshire and I'd go to um open shop
carpenters and talk to them and say you
know they would tell me what they make
what they what their benefits are Etc
and I would tell them what mine were and
what we had to offer well not mine our
our unions and what we had to offer and
they would get excited and they would
say yeah I'll I'll call you I'll be in
touch uh I would wait call them and then
they say well we're all set and I said
oh well good why is that well I told my
boss I was going to join the union they
gave me raises and they gave me
benefits I don't think that would have
happened had I not offered them that so
that that was just my only point thank
you I got a couple other in line
represent bushard is there something
specific very quick as a former
negotiator for a collective bargaining
unit
um an agency
fee that is charged for people who are
non-members for services provided by the
union needs to be agreed upon by both
manag
and the union so you so a union cannot
just impose an agency fee thank you
you're welcome repr Reser of Love
followed by K
Hill thank you Mr chair uh a couple
years ago when this bill came up I
remember um somebody testifying from the
well that uh union membership in non in
right to work states actually goes up 1%
so the the idea that this hurts unions
uh I I fail to fail to see that um you
know that's that's
[Music]
it representative
kahill thank you Mr chair you know
getting back to the agency fees which I
think we in agree with that people
should pay for what they get maybe not
pay the whole price because they don't
want to join a union and and this does
seem to be something that's uh probably
as my my friend Mr McKenzie said a
agreed to uh for some reason that people
wanted it to be this way I I don't think
we need to change that and I don't think
we need to change the law that would be
you seeing no other hands the motion on
the floor is an expedient to legislate
it's been moved and secondly we've had
role Vice chair seaworth
no prep bani no rep Prout no rep love no
rep Boyd no rep gagy no rep kcom no rep
drgo no rep Granger no ranking Dem
Sullivan yes rep buudy yes rep kahill
yes rep hacken Phillips
yes rep Susi
yes rep buard yes rep McKenzie yes
the clerk votes yes replic Clair yes rep
10 represent uh representative Granger
recognize for motion I move OTP and I'd
like to speak on my motion motion the
floor is ought to pass the amendment
seconded by representative love you
recognize to speak to your motion thank
you Mr chair I'm supporting OTP because
ultimately it's not about benefits it's
not about getting the fancy pay scale
that supposedly you get when you're in a
union job I could do without the union
Healthcare package I could do without
the pay I don't want any of it uh some
things are more important than pay and
benefit packages and what's regardless
of how cushy it is what's more important
is my Liberty I need to be independent I
need to be able to make my own choices I
need to be able to negotiate my own
wages the unions have stolen that from
me they have said that I am not allowed
to negotiate my own wages and to your
point I mentioned earlier that union
membership is declining well what does
that show you it's not it means that
people are choosing to isue unions and
so you might wonder what the relevance
of this is well it's about something
more important than the practicality or
how big of an impact is going to have
it's about the principle the fundamental
principle I should not be forced to pay
into a union that doesn't represent me
and you say Well they're supposed to
represent you I don't think they do and
I'm the one who deter whether I think
they represent me or not if they're not
doing what I think that they should be
doing I shouldn't be forced to pay into
them it's that simple the Cornerstone of
Liberty is the right to go to hack in
your own hand basket you should be if
you don't like my choices if you think
they're bad choices great let me make
them I can make whatever bad choices you
want whatever bad choices I want and uh
as far as independent workers go they're
routine you say that unions are so great
well then why are so many people
refusing to join unions if that's the
case oh all 90% of workers are not in
Union now it used to it used to be less
than
80% so and you say that uh this it was
mentioned that this is a issue with
federal law uh that we have these Free
Riders that aren't chipping in and uh
they need to have their wages garnished
for the benefit of the unions well blame
FDR I mean I'm a big fan of blaming FDR
for things just generally if you want to
add this to the pile go ahead but uh
don't call me a free rider and a scab
when I want to go my own way when I
don't want to do with the Union Sports
and then don't make me pay for it don't
make me pay for the people that are
stealing my funds who aren't
representing me other people in here
they seem to have been very happy
members of unions they seem to have
liked it very much I a proud non-union
worker I have I was a union worker for
about one month and then I I bounced I
was like I'm not going to do this
anymore and I come from a long line of
people who have never been workers or if
they were union workers it was let for a
very short time and then they left all
right and we're
growing so if you think the free riter
should find other jobs they're they're
going to they're going to find other
jobs I'm going to be supporting OTP on
this not because it makes a big impact
not because it matters because I don't
think unions are going to exist 50 years
from now I think they're going the way
of the dodo on their own without our
assistance this isn't union busting this
is just about principle and the
principle of the matter is I should not
be forced to Chuck money towards people
that don't that despise me let's be
honest unions despise me why should I be
[Music]
hands the motion on the floor is out to
pass removed in second have the
discussion uh Madam clerk please call
the role Vice chair storth yes rep
avalani yes rep Prout yes rep love yes
rep Boyd yes re gagy yes R kcom yes re
Dro yes R Granger yes ranking Dem
Sullivan no r buudy no rep kahill no rep
hackin Phillips no rep Susi no rep
bashard no
rep McKenzie no the clerk votes no
repair no rip do no Mr chair
10 before we move on to House Bill 1522
FN I requested that the Department of
Employment Securities uh come um give a
brief presentation of the information
that was provided uh by both uh myself
and um representative some of
Representative McKenzie's emails uh so
you can have questions I'd like to keep
the presentation and questions are about
minutes um and then we'll discuss some
some
uh discussions we've had with
representative sulliv and representative
McKenzie gentlemen if you take your
seats here representative
McKenzie uh Mr chairman the um some of
the comments May be related to an
amendment that has not been introduced
to this committee as yet so I have the
amendment
drafted um and so I I wasn't able to
share it because they only to share it
till comes in front of the committee so
if they're going to opine about uh 1522
the amendment 1522 maybe I should
and um
uh hold that thought okay I heard what
you said Mr Vice chairman yeah a sponsor
is free to share his Amendment at any
time so we don't need to enter executive
the do you do you have physical copies
of that yeah okay yes you feel free to
to pass those around I think it's
important to ol said don't share them
until the committee sees it so I haven't
shared it with anybody okay feel free to
to share them with the committee sure
um Mr chairman point of clarification
leave I believe what OLS said is that
they they won't share them but the
amendment sponsor is free to do what
they want right yeah yeah which is y so
um he's going to send those around um
uh La is and and uh Mr gley we're going
to speak um and then you'll have some
questions and then will explain
um kind of some concepts of of what
representative Sullivan McKenzie and I
have discussed briefly so gentlemen if
you take your position I have to uh go
to the men's room and representative uh
please
shot uh good morning members of the
committee just for the record Richard
lers Deputy Commissioner with the
Department of Employment Security and
joined by Brian gab director of the
economic and labor market information
Bureau of the Department of Employment
Security um what we uh have here will be
very uh quick and entertain any
questions that members have is a quick
rundown of the amendment that
representative McKenzie is proposing to
his bill um he's had a frequent
conversation uh with the Department as
he's been working on this um and we also
have uh some um material that discusses
a senate proposal that is also being
Amendment uh being amended uh from
Senator Perkins quoka um she had given
us um permission to share that um with
the labor committee uh so um I'll go
through some highlights of each of them
um kind of running through the a similar
um methodology as we did before and then
uh we have a few uh charts very few uh
that just look at trust fund impact on
the two amended proposals uh that folks
will recognize because you've you've
seen these same charts and graphs with
the original proposal so I'll I'll
circulate these uh Mr got will be
talking to these and I'll give you some
quick highlights on each of the amended
proposals so you can you know what we're
here Mr
chairman uh I also have um
if it's helpful for the committee um
what I received from the Department
which breaks down the the uh the two
legislation yeah maybe it' be helpful if
discussion should turn this on so these
are printed copies of the email we got
weekend there anybody that wants
them ahead all right um so I'll get
started with the the amendment to House
Bill 1522 from representative McKenzie
um so what we're looking at here is um
The Proposal would increase 35 of the
existing 52 benefit tiers as you recall
we have uh 50 2 um weekly benefit
amounts currently in our statute for the
unemployment program and then uh so it
increases 35 of those 52 uh it leaves
the bottom 17 levels of benefits as they
currently are and then it creates 19 new
benefit
tiers the wage replacement rate um would
uh stay at 60% at the lower end of those
benefit tiers and then would um end at
around
58% for the highend of the new tiers
that are being proposed the new maximum
weekly benefit amount um is
672 so our current maximum weekly
benefit amount that's been in place
since
2007 is
427 so that new maximum amount of 672
two that would put New Hampshire as
having the 12th highest weekly Max in
the country but as you recall um that
would still uh put us as having um one
of the lower weekly Maxes in the
Northeast uh so we'd still have the
fourth lowest weekly Max in the
Northeast um the proposal has a
staggered implementation schedule um it
would in introduce these new benefits TI
over 3 years so the full impact would be
would be phased in um we've focused on
the fully implemented impact um but it
is phased in so that the the
ultimately the benefit increases would
be
33% so a 33% increase in total benefit
payments over the base Baseline and that
would get phased in so in the first year
it'd be an 18% increase
and get this right and in the second
year it'd be a 27% increase and then in
that third year when you're fully
implemented you're at
33% um to compare that to the original
proposal the original proposal was close
to a 50% increase so this is
significantly scaled back from that
original proposal um but the the fully
phased in cost would be a 33% increase
on Baseline
benefits um shifting gears and looking
at the proposal being considered in the
Senate and hitting those same items that
I just discussed for the amended house
proposal uh so the amended or soon to be
amended Senate proposal from Senator
Perkins quoka um it does not touch the
current benefit schedule so our existing
52 benefit tiers would remain the same
with the Senate
proposal it creates 12 new benefit tiers
that would be stacked on top of those
existing
52 it would have a wage replacement rate
which is what we currently have of 60%
in those lower
tiers and then would top out at a
54% wage replacement rate at the new
high High
tiers the new Max weekly benefit in the
Perkins quoka proposal would be 669 so
$3 less than the house
proposal um those rankings for
nationally and in the Northeast would be
the
same the difference being that with the
Senate proposal the 669 weekly benefit
amount you would need to have earned
$65,000 in base period earnings uh
rather than $60,000 in base period
proposal the uh total increase in costs
with the Senate proposal is 26% over
Baseline um it's not a staggered
implementation so it would be uh
realized in the first year of
implementation so uh 26% with the Senate
amended proposal uh over Baseline the
house amended proposal is a 33% increase
over Baseline um so we have also looked
at the um impacts on the trust fund
forecast and the two stress test
scenarios that we had discussed before
with a modest recession and a Severe
recession and how the trust fund would
perform um director gotab has conducted
both of those and the uh chart that we
passed around summarize that and I'll
let let him talk to those starting with
1522 thank you um just to reiterate uh
the methodology we use here is an
econometric model that uh does trust
fund forecasting um has a number of
inputs I won't go through all of that um
but Rich pointed out the important
aspect in the difference in this
proposal the amended proposal is that it
increas Ines benefit payments by 33%
based on actual claims from
2023 adjusting them to the new benefit
schedule so 33% increase so we assume
that there'd be a 33% increase in
benefit payments um throughout the
forecast period um taking a look at um
the charts the second chart that I show
is the impact on our current Baseline
forecast for the trust fund which going
out to Q4
2025 is m m could you explain which
chart you're looking at there's a page
number or show it there is no page
numbers on this it um they're both
similar but this one is uh has House
Bill 1522 in the title at the
top so the the the first page shows a
33% difference um the second page is the
impact on our Baseline forecast our
Baseline forecast being
$393
million um with the new benefit schedule
we forecast that the trust fund would
end Q for 2025 at
$352 million almost $353
million and this is a no a no recession
scenario um some increase in claims and
unemployment claims uh as the economy
might soften a little bit in in hiring
the next chart is our begins our
recession models um basically what we
did in the first one the modest
recession we took the claim volume
adjusted for the current number of
employees in the state to a level that
is equivalent to the modest relatively
modest recession we had in the early
2000s so this is a a real life scenario
something that could actually occur and
what you see there is in that scenario
our Baseline forecast would just to
$337 million so that's if there were no
change in the benefit schedule if we
change the benefit schedule to the point
to the amended version then the trust
fund drops to$
265 million under this modest recession
scenario so it's a difference of about
$62
million the final chart is our severe
recession scenario and the severe
recession scenario scario is uh modeled
after the Great Recession Great
Recession for those of you I think I
mentioned this at the original hearing
on
1522 um it took us six years almost to
get back all of the employment that we
lost during the Great Recession so
really significant um the trust fund
actually did go negatively go negative
briefly requiring um the state uh to
borrow money from the federal government
um to to be able to pay the claims so a
a severe situation in that very SE
severe recession scenario our Baseline
would change without any adjustment to
the benefit schedule would go down to
$162 million still at a level um given a
a severe recession um while it's a
significant drop um we're not in danger
of going
negative um with the
adjusted benefit schedule as proposed in
1522 the amended version um we forecast
that the trust fund would drop to $106
million which is getting close to what
is considered uh a level of concern at a
at $100
million so about um a six $56 million
difference taking a look quickly at um
Senate Bill
436 the primary difference in the for
here is have you good I just ask you um
there's a there's a question and he
wants to have it before you get too deep
into this apologize no it's all right
trying to get through this quickly thank
you Mr lers thank you Mr gly um we're
looking at the back page of the severe
recession one just before we get too far
um it was six years to replace the
unemployment um workers how long did it
take how long did it take us to replace
balance you want to you
um well we in the actual Great Recession
so we ran out of money as director got
pointed out so we we were in the whole
120 million um they had to come back we
had to pay that back to the US Treasury
um how quickly the the fund came back to
that $250 250 million Mark where
employers were again getting discounts I
don't know the exact quarter off of off
of my head I can probably find it on our
website right now as
um director golob continues to talk and
then I'll be able to provide that to you
um when um when he's done with Senate
Bill
436 thank you and then I have follow-ups
after that if that's okay yes and then
kill after that
goe representative kill thank you Mr
chair and thank you gentlemen uh while
you're looking at that Mr labors would
you tell us approximately how much money
that cost the uh business owners in
you're really trying to see if I can
walk and chew gum at the same time well
you can you know have a piece of gum and
then you thank you um so a just a
reminder about how the uh discounts
themselves or fund balance reductions
operate in the total cost to
employers so um as we've we've um talked
about before so the discounts kick in
for employers right now at uh 250
million 350 million and 400 million so
when the trust fund achieves that
balance for every day of a calendar
quarter employers then get a reduction
in their earned rate the following
quarter and at 250 million that
reduction that employers get is
0.5% to their earned rate at 350 million
it is uh 1% reduction to the earned rate
which is what they are receiving right
now and that 400 100 million it is 1 and
a half% reduction to their earned rate
um new employers start at a
2.7% rate that gets paid on the first
$114,000 in annual earnings per
employee the uh current uh reduction we
have right now uh would take that new
employer from a 2.7% rate to a 1.7% rate
so those um amounts of those reductions
although they seem uh small uh when
you're just talking about a half point
and a point um they are significant with
regard to uh the rates that employers
pay employers right now are paying on
average uh
6% uh 6% rate uh that translates into
about $80 per employee per year in
unemployment insurance taxes at the
current rate with the 1% reduction that
they're currently receiving
follow follow
thank you Mr lab and so $80 a year for
insurance you you couldn't insure a
Chevy Vega for that could you and yet
we're ensuring employers
employment um my B my boss until
recently still had a Honda Prelude so I
don't know what his insurance costs were
you all right Mr gole if you would Char
continue where you were okay we'll move
on to Senate Bill
436 and the primary difference in the
forecast here um there is some
difference in the additional tiers that
were added um a little bit difference
but the main difference in it is that it
does not adjust any of the benefit
schedule for the current um set of tiers
so it only adds a set of tiers um and as
we talked about in the
original uh 1522 testimony one of the
issues that contributes greatly or most
significantly to our average weekly
benefit being low relative to other
states is the fact that we have half of
the beneficiaries earning more than the
maximum so the we pay benefits up to an
individual that makes 4
$1,500 currently so anything above that
the benefit does not increase when we
look at the actual claims more than half
of our claimants have earned earnings
that are higher than that so that
depresses the average weekly benefit so
that's the primary difference so this
bill Senate Bill 436 would increase
benefit payments by 26% as opposed to
33% in the U amended 1522 to that's the
first page the second page looks at a
back cast so um if you recall back we
back casted
1522 in our last testimony I won't get
into that but we looked at what would
have
happened taking the actual claims volume
from the previous two years and what
would have this proposed benefit
schedule 436 result in it would have
lowered
um the current trust fund balance by
about $32 million so going from 392 or
393 to
360 that's the first chart the second
chart looks at what the impact is on our
forecast our Baseline forecast we
generally try to forecast about two
years out one year we're very confident
in second year is a little bit more
difficult because economic conditions
can be difficult to project that far out
but um taking the new proposed benefit
schedule in 40 uh Center Bill 436 um we
forecast about a $29 million impact on
the current our current forecast so what
I would say is that while our forecast
may not be completely accurate at the
end of 2025 the real importance of doing
this kind of modeling is to look at what
the differential is to in whatever
forecast we come up with and whatever
the new benefits schedule is that's the
real value of it so we may not be right
on in our forecast but look at the
differential that's the key metric that
you want to look at so about a $29
million difference in the current
Baseline forecast taking a look at we
did the same thing we modeled it under a
modest recession similar to the early
recession and in that situation again
Baseline forecast would be adjusted with
no change in any benefit schedule would
be down to about 300 $137 million that's
the same as in
1522 this particular proposal um would
have a little bit less of an impact um
it would result in uh a forecast of $286
million uh about a $51 million
difference between the Baseline and um
the proposed uh in the proposed benefit
436 last
chart is the severe recession
scenario um and in that scenario again
obviously trust fund takes a very big
hit down to 162 million in our Baseline
forecast this proposal would bring it up
um would reduce that by an additional
$48 million to around $114
million so a bit better than what would
happen under 15 20 to um but still would
have a significant impact on the on the
trust fund again we're getting bit
dangerously down below or near that $100
million that begins to make uh people
who watch this closely very
nervous stop um and just one thing to
add to answer representative avani's
question so uh the trust fund uh reached
and maintained 250 million in the third
quarter of 2014
uh coming out of the Great Recession and
it U that following quarter employers
received a half Point reduction then
quarter after that it went up to a full
point reduction it did kind of kangaroo
around a little bit uh for a few
quarters and eventually employers were
were back to getting a 1 and a half%
reduction um up until uh the timing of
the
pandemic so it was third quarter of 14
million was that from 2001 or from 2008
that was from the Great Recession so
from the
200891 recession thank
you any further
questions all right well
shoot keep it sin synct please thank you
Mr chairman um given the fact that it
250 million and now right now we're at
$400 million do you see through your
claims benefits and the durations that
you did for these that people would stay
on these benefits longer with a larger
payout even a week or two weeks given
longer or and have did you factor in any
I want to say cushion but for that for
the duration of benefits to last a
little bit longer than the 449 that we
currently have in what we're looking at
right now and then I'll wait for the
next question
um I think it's important to point out
anytime you get into an economic
downturn your duration increases um you
know that's just the factual experience
that we've had with every downturn um
right now duration in New Hampshire one
of the lowest in the country lowest in
the Northeast we're at about 10 weeks um
what you see with the the two
proposals um is with the uh house
proposal your
wage replacement rate so the the the
amount of what your benefits represent
as a percentage of the wages that you
had while you were working um is
slightly higher than that under the
Senate proposal so the Senate proposal
doesn't do anything to the benefit tiers
that exist now so right now if you're
earning
$41,500 in your base period you get
$427 that's what you would get in in the
Senate proposal it's about a 54% wage
replacement rate the Senate proposal
brings those base period earnings up to
65,000 so that person would then get um
669 as a as a weekly benefit amount
which is
54% um at that maintaining that wage
replacement rate in a status quo type of
economy is what we have right now um I
wouldn't expect to see a shift in
Behavior as your wage replacement rate
isn't uh changing at all if you get into
a
downturn um duration will increase that
will increase regardless of what you do
uh to the benefit structure the house
proposal is a is slightly above that on
the wage replacement rate as I had
indicated it does it keeps the the
bottom 17 tiers as they are right now um
and then the 35 tiers above that um
moves them up slightly
and then um what you see in the 19 new
tiers proposed with the new maximum
benefit of 672 your wage replacement
rate is in the higher uh 50% range so
the 58% range so slightly higher wage
replacement rate uh than individuals
have right now at that Max weekly
benefit amount whether or not going from
a a 54% to a 58 is enough to shift
Behavior
and have an influence on duration um I'm
can't say precisely whether that would
have any impact or not I do have an
economist next to me if he wants to
suggest anything there I do and and this
is not an ideological statement
whatsoever but there's plenty of
economic research on on on behavioral
patterns related to unemployment
benefits and as the replacement ratio
increases significantly it does tend to
lengthen the duration of uh uh of
individuals on on benefits and we see
that in some of our neighboring states
Massachusetts has very high um benefit
uh payments compared to New Hampshire
doesn't have a dramatically different
economy and yet their duration there is
is significantly longer than is the
duration in New Hampshire so it's it's
just basic economics it does create
different incentives it's not again not
an ideological
statement
can you follow up please go ahead um is
that for is so say it's a 10% increase
in you in benefit duration is that in
this because I'm looking at the trust
fund and the cost it's going to be to
employeers to implement these
changes strictly that's all will is it
has it been forecasted in under the 2001
to 2008 and have you look even looked at
the covid issue if we have that again
coming up of of of a
different iteration
to have that
initial bom to the trust fund and a
Severe decrease and how would employers
or even even the agency if it was in the
second or third quarter come to build
that trust fund back up quickly so we're
not in the
negative I'll let the first part of that
question I believe is just about the
methodology if you want to address that
with the The increased duration yeah the
the we don't have in the model a
specific uh duration benef um variable
that we can increase so it's not
included however and I struggled to how
to explain this it's a a statistical
model that when claims are more severe
um the model knows that benefit payments
are going to go up kind of
disproportionately based on that volume
of claims not just the dollar but um so
it indirectly factors in the um the
impact of duration um this the model is
based on 20 more than 20 years worth of
data and how the the payments or the
trust fund reacts to the different
levels of claims we do not have the
pandemic in the model the pandemic was
not used to as for because it was an
anomalous situation it um you know much
of the unemployment was benefits were
paid by the federal government so it
didn't have a direct impact on the trust
fund so the pandemic experience is from
as an economist and statistician
perspective screwed up every time series
because it was so unique it messed up
everything so it's not included in that
situation and if it were to reoccur we
would have to you know wonder whether
the federal government would step in
again start paying many of the benefits
that the entire um eligibility changed
people who had never been eligible for
unemployment benefits prior to that
pandemic were all of a sudden um uh
eligible so we really couldn't include
it in the in the
modeling um the the second part of that
question how would the the department
handle it if you know looking at a a
regular um plain old downturn like we've
experienced before um so the current
tools that are in place right now to to
control for that because the the trust
fund and I've said this before it's
you're you're kind of looking for that
Johnny Cash moment right you kind of
want that uh that last check to bounce
the trust fund isn't all that uh
different than that you don't want to
over tax employers um to create a
balance that is more than you're going
to need to support unemployed workers in
your next downturn because if you're
creating a higher business climate a
higher tax climate that is directly tied
to the number of workers they have
employers will hire fewer workers so
it's a it's a um a balance that you try
to um meet where you're not over taxing
your employers um and not building your
fund to excess um but you're going to
have enough to withstand that next
downturn so that the state is able to
pay benefits not have to depend upon the
federal government um and borrow dollars
that could end up being very expensive
dollars for the Employers in that state
so what would happen is if we get into a
downturn um the very first thing that
would be happening um is that employers
would be losing those those fund balance
reductions um they would be coming off
as the uh balance of the trust fund is
falling uh that would then increase
their rates um and increase the amount
of taxes that they're paying it could
have a small impact depending on the
time of the year
that that is hitting so if an employer
doesn't have a seasonal flavor to their
employment pattern um and you're in the
third quarter when those when those fund
balance reductions are coming off that
might not have an impact on that
employer until you get to the first
quarter of the following year because
they've paid um the taxes on the first
$14,000 in annual earnings for the
employees for that existing year now
what happens with the earned rate that
gets adjusted on an annual basis uh in
each August employers get a tax rate
redetermination package from the
Department which takes into
consideration all of their experience so
all the benefits paid out to their
former employees all the taxes paid in
by that employer and it provides them
with their rate for the four quarters
going forward um that would also be
adjusted based upon higher benefit
payments going out um and um uh would be
adjusted to all of those factors so one
would assume their rate their experience
rate would be higher as well um you
could look at the when we go back and we
look at that average tax rate chart that
we had provided in the original
presentation employers currently are
paying at an average of
6% um when you look at what they are
paying at the uh peak of the uh pandemic
they are about 2 and a
half% so what that represents is about a
1 and 12% loss of their fund balance
reduction together with uh some
worsening of experience and so quickly
uh the rate you can go back up to that
uh 2 and a half% range but th those are
the levers that um are in are in place
right now uh new New Hampshire no longer
has sear charges in place that would be
added on to an employer's tax rate when
the fund drops um the uh
idea was that allow the fund to grow to
a higher balance during economic good
times like we're currently experiencing
with a fund that is close to 400 million
rather than where it would have been if
we hadn't made those adjustments we'd be
looking at a fund at around 300 million
right now um but allow the fund to grow
to a higher amount a true solvent amount
and that way you don't need to provide a
sir charge onto employers when times are
not so good so right now it' be the loss
of those fund balance reductions a
worsening of experience so when they got
their annual redetermination uh the the
rate the earned rate would be higher as
well that would try to drive in more
Revenue into the fund to try to keep up
um with those increases in dispersements
fund who Grangers first s right and then
represent uh thank you this might be a a
question for either you guys or the
chair um so this is referencing SB 436
as amended um but I looked up on I you
know where I could get that Amendment
because it's not on gen Court I guess um
I believe Senator Perkins quoka will be
providing it to the committee um she had
shared it um uh with the department and
had given the department permission to
share it with the labor committee as
well okay thank you so I can I can
actually provide uh that to uh chairman
infantine to provide out to the
committee thank you very much that would
be wonderful
PR uh thank you um my question is
regarding the um Behavior change you
mentioned regarding the average weeks of
unemployment usage as a line to the
maximum benefit amount um do you see
that having a greater effect in good
times than in a recession time simply
because it intuitively it seems in uh
either a moderate or severe recession
everyone goes to the maximum many ways
cuz they have having trouble and so I
would actually more see that change in
Behavior affecting the previous forecast
on the previous page of during normal
times like we are now and actually
moving the lines downward there more
than in the recession forecast and also
affecting the fund balance accordingly
can you comment on that at all no I I
think that's um an excellent point um
you know duration is going to lengthen
in the sever with the severity of the
recession regardless so um you know to
the extent that it Alters incentives to
to stay on unemployment longer it's
going to do so in a situation where
there is actually the choice to become
re-employ to work harder to become
reemployed or not that's more likely to
be a situation in a very mild or a more
mild recession or a normal economy when
because invariably people do get laid
off even in a non-recessionary economy
so it would probably impact that behav
behavioral those behavioral situations
in situations Le more so in the stronger
economy or a less severe recession in
the severe recession it probably doesn't
have as much of an impact and I think to
some degree that is reflected in these
forecasts where you know the difference
between the Baseline and the severe
doesn't seem to you know decrease
proportionately with the severity of the
recession so I think there is some of
that being captured in the model
thank you and just something to add
there there you know there's a lot of
talk coming out of the pandemic about
people making more on Unemployment uh
than they did in work which was a
function of how um the federal program
was created that paid unemployment
benefits uh during the pandemic with
initially an ex an additional $600 a
week and then an additional $300 a week
but for what we're talking about here
that's not that scenario at all here
we're talking about just state benefits
um with the two amendments you have uh
you know that person getting that Max
benefit you're either at a 54% wage
replacement with the Senate proposal or
a 58% wage replacement in the house
proposal you're not getting rich in
either of those scenarios and I think um
there's still quite a bit of incentive
for you to be returning to employment
when your when your wage replacement
rate um is just a a a little bit above
50% of what you were making while you
were
employed representative kill thank you
Mr chair thank you gentleman again uh I
know that these uh discounts are very
important because as I recall we were
talking about Federal money and I know
the governor took 15 million in arpa
money and applied that to the
unemployment trust fund to hasten those
uh half% reductions for the community so
so I know we think about the those
reductions being important and and
changing employer Behavior Uh and we
also talk about the uh increase in the
benefit changing um employee Behavior
will they be looking for work if they
have a little bit more money in their
pocket uh to spend on paying their bills
uh buying things in their Community
paying their taxes whatever uh so is is
it fair to say that uh this is a modest
Improvement that is really
uh either way with the senate or the
house bill that it's kind it's kind of
time we should do this so that people
are not going to be scraping by but
maybe a little bit more comfortable as
they seek the to to replace the entire
uh paycheck they were
getting um well you know we'll leave it
up to to you folks whether or not it's
time uh to do this what I can tell you
is
that looking at these proposals with the
the benefit tiers that that are
contained within each of them they don't
raise any alarms with the wage
replacement rates uh that are being
proposed um you know the the I think the
original wage replacement rates in in
House Bill 1522 the original proposal I
think um uh were higher um than um uh
you would normally see uh within an
unemployment program that's properly
structured to incentivize a return to
employment um but you know both
proposals that we're looking at now with
wage replacement rates um in the 50s you
know that the Senate proposal in the
lower 50s the house proposal in the
higher 50s um neither of those raise any
alarms thank you one comment I I think
the you know when I look at the benefit
schedule um this is one of the the
current benefit schedule this is one of
the rare policies where higher income
folks are more
disadvantaged um you know people who are
making above 41,500 have the lowest
replacement rates the replacement rates
at the lower half or the the current
below 40 anyone making 415 or below are
well within the national averages that's
you know kind of where around a 50
anywhere from 50 to 60% replacement rate
that seems to be where Most states are
it's at the top of those making more
than
415 um where we disadvantage workers
you thank you Mr chairman um you
mentioned the 54 and the 58% is that
gross or net replacement is it replacing
58% is their gross pay or 58% of their
net pay uh that's their gross pay thank
you and follow Mr
chairman um so you talked about the
positive negative ratings for employers
would this widen the gap between
negative and positive um employers
because of the use of additional
benefits at the higher
tiers um given seasonal I'm not to call
anybody out but seasonal employers would
be typically have the highest negative
ratings and the positive employers would
have to I don't want say subsidize but
make up that difference in the trust
fund
as um so so with your your positive and
negative rated employers the
um if if an employer had had experience
that was teetering right on the edge of
uh going from positive to negative or
vice versa um an increase in benefits
going out to their former
employees um could uh tip them um
towards that that negative rating where
they have more benefit payments going
out
um overall um I I don't see that as
significant uh with the the proposals
that we're talking about here um but if
you were an employer that was close to
going negative um I can see you know an
increase in benefits depending on what's
going on um with your employment pattern
um and increase in benefits um could
have an impact and it it could have an
impact on your experience rate as
well we're also talking about the fund
balance uh reduction uh balance
thresholds would those be
changing in 1522 or 436 and what would
the impacts be for a negative and a
positive employer um the amended version
of House Bill 1522 does not um at at
least Le the version that I've seen does
not um uh propose any change to the fund
balance reduction thresholds the Senate
proposal does uh so um right now like I
had indicated we're at 250 million 350
and 400 uh the Senate proposal uh would
go up to uh 300 3 no sorry 350
375 and
450 and interestingly because of where
the trust fund currently is right now
and forecasted to be right in that um
you know mid 390s to low $400 million
range uh that would actually not have an
impact on the forecasted fund balance
reductions that employers um are
forecasted to get through the end of
20125 again because of where we are with
our existing balance and what those
proposed amounts are now certainly there
would be an impact um coming out of the
next downturn um where employers that
were accustomed to getting a half Point
reduction when the fund returned to 250
million um they wouldn't see that until
the fund returned to 350 million so
there would be an impact down the road
but there would not be an impact in the
immediate um shortterm uh forecast for
where the trust fund currently
is well
um was that factored into the from the
2008 to 2014 that we spoke about earlier
for the fund balance to regain its
traction out of the good re the Great
Recession has that been facted into
right now if that happened again what
you just spoke
about there was no adjustment to the um
in either of these forast to the fund
balance reduction
triggers so we didn't factor that those
into either of these um either of these
forecasts and how long would it be to
get from let's say we draw drew it down
to 100 million in a big downturn how
long would it be for us to get employees
back up to the 450 so they can get back
to it it' be it would be very very
difficult um one because while you're
the benefit payment would consistently
be higher the tax rates would be higher
so you just reach a different
equilibrium and
it you know at whatever benefit schedule
you have you're going to reach an
equilibrium point eventually um we're
kind of at that right now around 400
million but if we adjust the benefit
schedule it's going to change and that
equilibrium level is probably going to
go down um but you I can't we can't we
haven't modeled that so it's difficult
to say but um I don't expect that we
would get to 450 million um it would not
my lifetime I'm getting near the end of
it um it it it's difficult because you
don't I mean it's all influenced by the
pace of hiring right so coming out of
the Great Recession an incredibly slow
pace of hiring director gotop talking
about six years to get back to the level
of employment private sector employment
that we had prior to the Great Recession
you know then spin forward to the
pandemic um and we
had a very quick return um with robust
hiring coming out of that so um all of
that influences the taxes that are being
paid by employers that are going back
into the trust fund to build up that
Reserve so it's difficult if not
impossible to predict what that pace of
hiring would be coming out of that
downturn thank you and my final followup
Mr chairman final are we looking to
increase
the fund balance to 450 million before
all um benefits not benefits all
reductions are had by employers because
it's looking like we've been hovering at
400 million are we looking to increase
that to 450 and stay at 450 for the
foreseeable
future um that is contained within the
Senate proposal
yes repr kill and then I'm going to move
on thank you Mr chair and thank you once
again for your patience uh so again
we're talking about the uh the discount
the half% maybe 1% an experience rating
and all of this only applies to the
first
14,000 uh the one a year for one for
each employee
correct correct that F that 14,000 is
the taxable wage base that um the um
experienced tax rate um gets app gets
applied to and determines what that tax
liability is for the employer follow up
follow and do you have your calculator
handy what is that what does 14 what is
half a percent of
14,000
representative I went to law school to
avoid
math $70 $70 that's what that's that's
like why we have an economic and labor
market information Bureau perfect thank
you so
much all right thank you gentlemen
appreciate
it so
um the bill in front of us is uh
1522 representative McKenzie uh sent
um representative you're going to sit
back over here in your chair so we can
Amendment so let me talk about a little
bit of uh discussions that
representative seaworth Sullivan
McKenzie and I have
had um I
prefer the Senate bill
uh because it happens immediately versus
tiered and there's some other things I
like in it but um and and from my
understanding it's going to have some
pretty good legs in the
Senate um and but I don't want
to um in case something goes
ay on its way over here I don't want to
not have a bill to deal with on this
side we're in the second year of a turn
so I can't can't retain it it has to go
to inter room study and then you can't
pull it
off what can be done is whether we vote
10 to 10 here in the committee it goes
to the house floor representative
McKenzie and I agree that we table the
bill um and we wait and see what comes
over uh at that point if it comes over
it's been messed up we don't like it we
have representative uh we we can amend
it here from the Senate Bill if if it
doesn't come over from the Senate we can
come up with uh any kind of amendments
we
want uh and uh move it off the table if
we all if we agree to to where it's
going we can move it off the table um in
the house with the
amendment strategically I don't know any
other better way to skin the cat
representative
Sullivan yeah the basically if we
anything else we do with the bill it's
it's gone it's dead um and I think this
strategy and I think a 10 to 10 vote is
fine um I think it it leaves us with an
ought to pass um well leaves us with no
recommendation which goes to ought to
pass so if we needed to deal with it on
the um house floor um in all likelihood
we would be dealing with an amendment
and it would be well positioned that way
um to take amendments um
okay he said he could stay till one no
he
left I don't think so I'm not sure any
someone could you check
please
just I guess we'll see if we have a 10
to 10 um but uh but I I regardless uh I
think it would be helpful if if it was
positioned with an ought to pass um when
when we uh get to the floor if if we
have
to engage in the circus hopefully the
Senate bill will come over we'll deal
with it appropriately it'll become um
the bill that goes to the floor um but
if um if that doesn't work um I I would
encourage us um to have either 1010 vote
if we have our people or um an aut toass
outcome so that um we don't have to go
through the
um the process of
uh um overcoming an
itl then moving um a to pass then moving
an amendment um and then getting it
through I mean basically it just seems
to be um a cleaner way for us to proceed
if we have to engage in this uh
exercise R McKenzie
pine I mean I I think it's important to
uh I think it's important to uh keep
this uh legislation alive there are a
lot of commonalities between the Senate
version and the house
version um and I think uh overarching is
that there needs to be something done uh
to increase the uh the unemployment rate
in the state it's been since 200 seven
since they made any changes to this and
uh especially those people at the top
you you're seeing a you know a real uh
uh inequity uh between the replacement
rate that they they enjoy and those
people are in different places in the
schedule and this legislation tried to
even that even that out so I think I I
think we have an opportunity to uh you
know to get together with the Senate I
tried to get a hold of those people
contacted all of them I wasn't able to
uh connect with them but uh I think we
can keep this alive um I think it makes
a whole lot of sense and and what
representative Sullivan is saying is
that we we try to do the art to pass and
uh you know and then on the floor we
table it I would I agreed with the uh uh
that yeah representative barudi had to
um he's a court mediator he had to be in
Salem by 1 p.m. so he did
leave we we both thought we would have
been done by now um I don't think we he
realized we were going to do a work
session or he had planned to be here for
votes
chicken I I just think we have to do
something it's been 15 years we need to
do something um representative
McKenzie's has a little time period
That's is why the the threeyear phase in
which is why his numbers in a recession
or higher I like to implement it
immediately I like the stepping I I
discussed in the Employment Securities
Advisory Board the 250 350 400 is too
low where the trust fund needs to be now
okay as as as a percentage of if you
look back and where when I first started
this gig it was like 200 250 27 5 or
something um it hits a lot of the points
uh I'm not saying we can't make some
amendments we got to see what comes over
um I'm just realistic that if we if we
pass something over to the Senate that
is is is different significantly
different and from theirs that they're
just going to dismiss it anyway and I
just I want to keep it as a kind of a
thing on the side so I think we all kind
of agreed is this kind of the strategy
of what it's going to do we're going to
do the 99 to make it easy for everybody
and then um representative McKenzie and
I on the floor we'll we'll speak to uh
the tabling um together and and and we
move forward with what the sener brings
over representative Sullivan yeah just
very quickly I I with regard to the two
bills Senate and House I I can live with
either one um I think they both
accomplish what I would like to think
that we all want to accomplish um which
is uh you know ra raising that U maximum
salary
um so at any rate um I'm I'm good with
this going forward and
um I'm ready to vote all right we're g
to just one moment please yeah do you no
do you want to speak on the concept or
no this is really weird but in the next
five minutes I have a delivery coming so
I will I just sorry to that's all right
we
um I I I would I I would recommend we
support the amendment that being that's
going to be presented by representative
m McKenzie as we go forward here
okay so representative McKenzie you're
recognized to make a motion so my motion
is
amendments is it 0561
H 0561 H has been moved seconded by
representative kill you recognized to
speak to your
motion I think that U I think a good
step forward we have an opportunity
perhaps to get together with the Senate
to make some uh you know to make some
ask see no one uh
further no one else would like to speak
Madame clerk please call the role
motions ought uh ought to pass motions
to amendment to remove the amendment
approve the amendment Vice chair
seaworth yes rep avalani yes rep Prout
yes rep love yes rep Boyd yes rep gagy
of course uh rep kcom
yes rep drgo yes rep Granger yes ranking
D Sullivan yes rep Rudy no here rep kill
yes rep hackin Phillips yes rep Susi yes
rep rard yes rep McKenzie yes the CL
votes yes repair yes rep stab yes Mr
chair yes
180 okay now the motion on the floor is
ought to pass with
Amendment that's representative McKenzie
you going to make that
bushard any any discussion on your
Amendment okay you know we're we know
what we're going to do here right okay
roll we got to give the clerk a second
here to write the stuff up all right I'm
ready um uh Vice chair seaworth
no rep avalani no rep Prout no rep love
no rep Boyd no rep
gagy rep kcom
ranking D Sullivan yes rep Rudy no not
here not a know um rep kill yes rep
hockin Phillips Phillips rep Susi yes
rep bushard yes rep McKenzie yes rep uh
the clerk votes yes rep lir yes rep stab
yes Mr chair No 9
to9 representative sew you recogniz from
motion I make a motion to itl and uh itl
uh a motion seconded by representative
Prout I speak you may speak so so just
briefly uh my point in making this
motion is to advance the plan that we
had what I'll write up in the blurb is
that about that we have this alternative
in the Senate and um I want to support
the action that we've
discussed see no other
discussion Madame clerk please call the
r
okay Vice chair seaworth yes rep avalani
yes rep Prout yes rep love yes R Boyd
yes rep
pulam yes rep drgo yes rep Granger yes
Hill sorry about that uh R pack and
Phillips no R Susi no R Bru Shard no R
McKenzie
no the clerk votes no rep
lir no rep stab no Mr
chair yes
99 all right thank you very much for
that
yes oh who
seconded so seor oh seaworth uh proud
thank
you yes I think the rest are going to be
I think pretty academic but yes um Drago
would you go get representative
uh gagy
hearing and I'd like to thank um uh
assistant Commissioner of unemployment
Securities Mr lers for uh doing all of
his work when he was sick as a
dog um
um working at home and trying to pull
himself into the office so thank you
very
much everyone has no idea the time and
effort you and your uh office put into
all of this so thank
you the next bill is House Bill 1597 FN
I recognize representative seaworth for
a motion chairman I have an amendment
thank you Mr chairman um I would move
interim
study uh motion for is uh interim study
uh by uh seaworth seconded by
representative drego your I to speak to
your motion thank you very much Mr
chairman I like this bill um and it it
took me a while when I first looked at
the text I didn't get it then the
sponsor started explaining what he
wanted to do and I started to get it and
then I went home and I made some charts
and I made some spreadsheets and I did
LUN of
calculations and and I really get it um
I I think though the amendment that he
gave us uh when we had the public
hearing is not
quite
ready um it has some problems and I
could go into those problems but having
moved interim study I'd probably lose
some of the support I have cuz now if we
vote interm study then we don't have to
go into the details and the spreadsheets
and the calculations of the graphs now
we can wait and do that in interim study
the real reason I'm asking you to
interim study this bill is I think it's
premature we just spent a lot of time
talking about two bills one in the house
one in the Senate that are proposing
some very large changes to the overall
unemployment
structure and this is a little change
that has to do with what happens when
somebody's earning some
part-time that's the tail of the dog
that is the whole package so any
assumptions that I would make any of
those calculations I did are all thrown
out the window when we adopt some new
tables which from what I've heard it
sounds like that's that's pending some
some time before the end of the year
furthermore uh the Deputy Commissioner
has said that he has some more data that
he can provide about what happens um
with people who are on unemployment but
also getting part-time I think that
would be very valuable in evaluating
potential amendments um I
have an idea of what would be a good
amendment that I think solves all of the
problems that I've identified with the
um original proposal I know
representative kahill also has an
amendment that um could
[Music]
solve maybe not exactly the same set of
problems that I'm solving but also solve
those problems um I could very well be
convinced that your version is better
than mine or I might think my version is
better also again I think a better um
discussion to have uh within the context
of an interim study and preparing a
report for once we know how we've
changed unemployment then what's the
right way to solve this problem that was
presented to us so I would ask you um
whether you think this bill is a good
idea or a bad idea or whether um if
you've seen my charts and graphs if you
if you like my idea if you if you like
what uh representative kahill is is um
proposing I would ask you um to agree
with me that interim study is a proper
approach to deal with this bill at this
time thank you k Mr chairman I uh I
haven't seen the charts and graphs uh
but I did have some reservations about
uh about the bill itself uh there were a
lot of rather drastic changes to how
what what would be uh excluded and not
concluded and I think the uh the I've
also had a conversation with Mr lers and
I think the simple adjustment to the uh
to the disregard would be something that
we could do without gumming up the whole
works and would be a positive step for
those people who are who are look who
are offered an opportunity to work uh
maybe a few days or a or a day or two uh
and then have to do the calculation as
to whether or not uh the cost for their
child care the cost for this the cost
for that and then they lose so much of
their benefits uh I think expanding to
uh from 30 to 40% for the disregard is a
reasonable step and it doesn't uh
harm SE I was hoping not to do any math
today um
but
so it is
difficult to make that determination
without knowing what that limit's going
so if the um maximum weekly benefit
amount remained at 427 and the cap
128 I could agree with your assessment
because I've done that calculation it's
it's mid
$50 that would that would someone would
earn extra 40 it's only 40 no I thought
it was 128 to
170 go ahead doesn't matter regard
um but what if it goes to a number that
we don't know what that is yet and can
we say that that won't have one of the
problems there are number several
problems with Bill uh besides its
complexity another one that I had an
issue with and I think probably you have
an issue with is what happens at the
very low end when you're making say $50
part-time just working a couple hours
right now you get that over and above
your check under the the language of the
pro proposed Bill you'd only get a
portion of that and I don't think any of
us likes the idea of taking money away
um from someone who was getting so
little to begin with so that would need
to be solved the other issue though and
and I I think your version does solve
that the other issue though was the one
that the Deputy Commissioner brought up
that this idea of at what point
does adding benefits that aren't paid
now create an incentive and that we'd
see people staying on on in the system
longer and that's the one that I can't
answer if I to me I need to know what
the numbers are to be able to evaluate
that and that's why I'm saying let's do
these in sequence let's know what that
number is it won't be 170 anymore it
might
be two 220 something I don't know
there's another number that's up there
that's higher in fact substantially
higher than the change we're talking
about would be this un unknown change
that comes when the other bill passes so
that's why I'm asking that we consider
them in sequence let's know what we're
looking at before we propose the change
repres
Sullivan Mr chairman I'm Wonder
wondering if there might be some value
to um having U Mr lers weigh in on this
so that uh we can take advantage of his
expertise as long as he's
here yeah that's
fine I know I've discussed it with him
so I know what he's going to say so
that's
fine
good to see
everybody um the original Bill the
department had concerns with regard to
the the changes that were going to be
made with uh what would be regarded as
earnings and what would not um and also
we had concerns with the mechanical
changes to how the earnings disregard
would be applied uh what is being
discussed now goes back to what we have
what we currently have and that the when
we're when we're looking at an earnings
disregard an individuals allowed to have
part-time employment and those part-time
uh dollars need to uh then be reported
to the department so we can determine
whether or not it needs to um make an
causes an adjustment to their weekly
unemployment benefit the denominator is
the weekly unemployment benefit not the
amount of earnings that they get um so
if we go back uh to that uh the
department is much more comfortable um
with looking at the maintaining the
existing structure whether or not the
amount of the uh earnings whether it's
the the disregard is at
30% uh or
40% I think you know that's left um to
the committee to decide uh what you want
to do with that but the department for
from where where our concerns were
originally um those would be addressed
by going back to U maintaining the
existing structure um and then looking
at whether or not the amount of earnings
that someone is allowed to keep before
it impacts their unemployment um whether
or not that's the right amount now we
are um I'm expecting hopefully this week
um representative seaworth had mentioned
this that um a a data query of the 2023
claim filers that will show the number
of
individuals um that had part-time
earnings that were less than 30% of
their weekly benefit amount and we'll
show the number of individuals that had
part-time earnings that were more than
30% of their weekly benefit amount so we
can actually see it in real life uh what
that looked like in the 2023 claim
filing year um and you'll also be able
to see how much of the maximum benefit
available to those individuals uh were
utilized and did it make a difference uh
for those that were below that 30%
versus those that were above U because
it's really um when you um look at
impact on the trust fund that's where
the you'd be able to derive that impact
would be does that does allowing someone
to retain um more of their weekly
benefits amount um when they have those
part-time earnings do they stay with
that part-time employment longer
supplemented with their with their
unemployment benefit um and thus utilize
more of their maximum benefits available
having more of a draw down on the trust
fund versus someone being more
incentivized to return to full-time
employment so as soon as those numbers
are available we'll provide those uh to
um uh the chair and vice chair uh to be
distributed out to the committee but I
think that will be helpful information
uh to have uh to look at what what
currently you see with with the impacts
and what the claim filing population
looks like with the number of part-time
earners above and below that current
threshold
Solin it seems like if we're waiting for
um data from the Department um and this
bill does not have to be voted out today
Bill okay
um I was going to suggest that we get
the data and um see if we can still do
something with this the the the thought
process that I I that I come up with is
a couple different items we get the
information um we can have
representative seaworth and Cahill go
talk to the senator to see whether or
not when that bill comes over here
would she agree to add this amendment to
it because then we'll know the numbers
we'll know all the different things
there a delicate balance here between
having someone have too many part-time
jobs which is against the concept of
getting them full-time benefit full-time
work and not making that giving them
enough like because you know I I like
you guys think that someone shouldn't be
if if they have a full-time job and a
part-time job they lose a part-time job
full-time job and you take away the
benefits of the a lot of the the
you hit them because they're making
money in the the parttime I don't like
but I also can't have three or four
different want people having three or
four different part-time jobs and making
so much that there's no incentive that
that so there there's that delicate
thing and right now the two the concept
between the bill versus how we do it now
are a little different so that was the
the concept whether we do it ourselves
add it on to M representative McKenzie's
if something doesn't happen in the
Senate
or ask the senator to approve it to add
it as an amendment or see if she would
be agreeable that if we were going to
add it to Amendment here if we agree
with it when it goes back to them
knowing well that they are going to
accept it but I don't think it makes a
lot of sense because right now and I'm
sorry you don't have these charts but
Brian went crazy on these these things
um on on all these things there is a
deficit if if you if if you go with the
K's Amendment someone making a little
bit actually gets hurt they make less
than they would have under the current
law well that's not what we want to do
that's the original bill that's the
other way right original right's
Amendment I'm sorry I I I my apologies
so I just want to make sure we have all
the things right and with with what's
going to go go on and what is the
purpose of of passing the bill with an
amendment now to the house floor with
this when we don't have the information
and we still have a mechanism to put it
through that's that's where I was coming
from you don't have to agree with me but
that's the thought process I had
represent that
said
um and I'm just going go right out there
and say I will support the interim study
um with the understanding that you know
and frankly the the issue that U
representative McKenzie is addressing
with his bill the Senate is addressing
with their bill um is the important
issue that that's that's really where
we're going to make some improvements to
the system um this is a tweak that I
think could help some folks out um it
would
um it but it would be a modest
Improvement to the system and if we have
to wait on one or the other I'd rather
wait on this one than the other
representative seaworth would you uh
would I be accurate in stating that the
goal of the interim uh study here is not
to trash it but to actually study it get
the numbers and have an answer to this
I believe so and I'd like to add one
caveat
um that the sponsors of this bill were
trying to
address a specific problem
that isn't necessarily addressed by
simply raising the cap um and that had
to do with uh so let's say I'm I'm
getting my
$427 a week and I take a parttime shift
a friend of mine has a mini Mark so I
take one shift I get $128 a week I get
to keep that because it's under the cap
the next week he says can you work two
shifts I say sure don't mind in that
case I'm going to lose every dollar I
make coming out of of my check so I've
worked now two shifts but I still make
the same as when I work one ship the
next week I might not know that because
I've filled out my forms I've turned
them in I don't know what's happening my
check the next week he says you know
what I that guy who was out he quit can
you work four shifts this week and I'm
still
part-time I would now work four
shifts and I wouldn't make a single
penny more than when I work one and
that's the problem that they sponsors
asked us to look at this disincentive
to work more and possibly and this is
where where these numbers come in
important possibly the the number of
people that accidentally work more not
realizing they're actually going to see
less money overall once taxes and Social
Security and Medicare gets calculated in
simply raising the
cap moves people out maybe fewer people
are are affected by it but that point
where you keep working twice as many
three times as many four times as many
hours and you get nothing we're not even
addressing that so that my long response
is I I've never heard a short response
no that each time I get a little longer
and remember that next time you ask me a
question um so this longer response
is that when I'm proposing an interim
study I'm hoping to address address more
than just wait and run the numbers I'm
hoping to address the concerns of the
people who brought this bill for us and
does it does it solve their problem
adequately do they think it doesn't even
address what they've put forth um so
amending out their intent because we
want to quickly act on this I think does
as much a disservice to this bill
as not addressing it within this term
thank you representative K Hill and
avalani thank you Mr chair I I do uh
agree with the information it' be
helpful to have the data and I'm
relieved to know that the plan is not to
wait and see if it has Merit for next
term because that would be
disappointing uh however I'd also hope
the deputy will find out how many people
were in that situation where they worked
a week worked two weeks and didn't get
anything I think that's going to be a
bit of an anomaly
it should be yeah should know not to do
that but so hopefully we can get this
sorted out and do more than one thing at
once
[Music]
representative thank you Mr chairman um
I like the conversation that we were
having and we're going to take a deeper
look at this but for the Deputy
Commissioner um at the 40% in our
current
structure the phase is 128
if we were to change that what would the
phase be at the 40% at our higher end
since more I'm guessing more people
would be at that higher end
to phase that and would with 35% maybe
be the number we should look at for to
balance the longevity with
the amount being earned on the
side no we didn't rehearse this right
the math that I did because even though
I had indicated I sought to avoid math
by going to law school my father was my
AP Kelk teacher so there is some math in
there somewhere um but just quickly
looking at the 30% disregard right now
you're at that 427 Max you're allowed to
keep the first
$128 in earnings without any impact on
your benefit if we move that Max benefit
up to 66 9 uh then you'd be looking at
$21 with our current 30% disregard is
what you'd be able to keep without any
impact so you'd have the 2011 in
earnings plus the 669 in benefit if we
increase that 40% disregard to increase
the disregard to
40% then um if our Max was still at
$427 a week that person would be able to
earn
$171 without any impact and and if we
increased the benefits to 669 that
person would be able to earn uh
267 without any impact on their
unemployment
benefit quick followup so the 267 is
that a net takehome or is that again on
their gross payments on they they report
their gross thank you to us thank you
Mr kale so again these maximums we we
right now we have 60% of the people
hitting the maximum if we raise that
maximum that number is going to be quite
a bit smaller
correct correct um so right now you get
60% of the claim filers in 2023 hit that
427 um what we looked at with both the
Senate and the house proposal uh you'd
be looking at about 30% of claim filers
hitting that that new Max so instead of
4,000 people hitting the max you got
2,000 people hitting the max follow so
again the the the beauty of using a
percentage is that as inflation or wages
Rises and cost Rises it goes with it it
doesn't uh it doesn't lag uh so this
there some benefit to this change yes uh
I think there's a there's benefit to
keeping the percentage absolutely there
are other States including uh Maine that
do it as a flat dollar amount I think
the percentage uh is a better way to go
um so I you know keeping it as a
percentage I would strongly encourage
thank
you right we have a motion on the floor
study it's been moved and seconded by
don't
remember and cworth and Dro that's
right we've had the discussion motions
um please Madam clerk call the
rooll vice chair seaworth yes rep
avalani yes rep Prout yes rep love yes
rep Boyd yes rep gagy yes rep kcom yes
rep drgo yes rep Granger yes ranking D
Sullivan
yes rep
kahill
yes rep hackin Phillips yes rep Susi yes
rep Shard yes rep McKenzie yes the clerk
votes yes repair yes rep stab yes Mr
agenda all right thank
you House Bill 1375 relative to servance
agreements required representative
seaworth
uh no I'm already writing two so if
someone else wants to make that well I
remember representative balani thank you
Mr chairman I move
itl been moved by representative balani
second by representative Granger you're
uh recognized to speak to your motion
thank you Mr chairman um this seeks to
make several adjustments to um Severance
agreements and
um uh just for one side instead of both
sides and we don't do that here thank
you repres
Sullivan not really sure what he just
said
but um the um I support the itl I I
think this defeats the entire purpose of
a severance agreement um and um uh
therefore it ought not to happen
any other comments see with no no just
waitting for Madam
clerk the Motions on the floor removed
seconded
discussion please call the role Vice
chair seaworth yes rep balani yes rep
Prout yes rep love yes rep Boyd yes rep
gagy yes rep kcom yes rep drgo yes rep
green
yes ranking Dam Sullivan yes repy is not
here um rep kahill yes rep hackin Smith
Smith Phillips I don't know why I wrote
Smith sorry yes thank you if I were
perfect I'd be annoying rep Susi yes rep
bushard yes rep McKenzie yes the clerk
votes yes rep La Clair yes rep stab yes
Mr chair yes 19 to
zero consent yes
yes um I uh had requested um a
subcommittee uh we received a
significant Amendment on the pay cards
uh I just um think it deserves its due
uh not making any aspirations anyway
shape or form I had requested any kind
of volunteers I know represent balani
volunteered I would like uh one more
Republican and and two Democrats you
don't have to give it to me now
representative Sullivan I'd like
to representative Susi H and K Hill
thank
you I guess I'll do
it
um um just to to see where it is I I
still don't think
yeah we'll disc we'll discuss that any
uh finisher I was going to say stay back
I was going to let everyone else who
needs to go go and then um with with
with regard to that um committee report
on um representative McKenzie's bill it
seems like the two rep
reports I mean we are not in
disagreement as to where we're going on
this and
um I'm wondering if uh we just put one
report in um if if there's not a second
report written it won't be
printed I'm happy to do that I'll type
it here and let you look at it make sure
it's uh even with everybody uh with what
we both agree on that that that sounds
good I think it did because if there's
two reports people will be reading them
anticipating that they are in opposition
to each other corre um and if we're not
there then why confuse people
understood kill uh would you like to
take the same approach on 1178 that U an
amendment is uh in progress and
desirable and uh no real contest it's
found
um I'm I'm thinking for a second I don't
have a problem with it
but is the goal to table this thing when
we get to the floor if we don't have
that's a different the goal is to have
it done by then right okay that's fine
Mike any other before this committee
representative gagy you're writing all
the blurs so you can
stay Thank you
for thank you to our fill uh people that
filled in today the Comm labor committee
thank you for everybody for your
diligence today have a good day
the this itl
report it better not say we're
supporting an amendment that we haven't
seen yet
because that's what he wants he wants
you to say oh we're going to come up
with a better Amendment on that's the
only reason
works
he's not on it it's the four of us
yeah I thought it was Susi no that's the
other one that's the other one what are
you talking the one you scheduled for
right now uh it's on the it's on the um
yes
oh
okay um
wonderful and
um if you were representative kahill
hoping to talk about the discussion that
you had in the email you're welcome to
us all right thank you um so I think
where we stand with
this with this
bill
is I put in a number
um which would
raise the the limit from 300 to
3,000 and we're trying to answer the
question is is that the right number is
there a better number we can come up
with um I would also uh be interested if
anybody has an opinion one or two
members mentioned that maybe it
shouldn't be a fixed dollar number but
uh somehow related
to a pay period or or something like
that so those are the kind of
discussions I think we want to have and
at the end of it um come up with a
recommendation um either for a new
dollar number a new approach for
calculating it
or or no change whats we could leave it
as it is um we could if the idea is that
leave leaving it as it is does nothing
and we want to no no okay that's not
what I meant I said I meant no change
leave the bill as it is yes y so um
that's where I'm hoping to get to today
I will start because I see the
department is here did you have
information that you wanted to uh
because
if you have questions for us and you
know what I'm going to start with a
question to you because I had
um I was having a discussion earlier and
I think I know what the answer is but I
didn't agree with the person asking it
so in the the way the law is written
and let me see if I
can yeah
um so it says that the the wages
due are paid by the employer not in
excess of and let's just use the 3,000
so not in excess of 3,000 May upon
proper demand be played in paid in the
absence of actual notice of the pendency
of prodate
proceedings and the question somebody
asked is what happens if it's over 3,000
so it's
$3,100
I would say then you
can't you can't pay it it has to the
whole amount has to go to
probate the other opinion was that the
employer can pay $3,000 and anything in
excess of that has to go to probate and
it's really a question of the exist this
isn't this is the existing language so
the question isn't even what I intended
or or what I thought I was doing it's
how does has the
years oh I'm sorry I'm stretching red
light means on all right I'm not I'm
terrible with the technology um you know
one first and foremost in engaging with
our Inspection Division and I believe
that uh attorney McGrath had testified
to this over the course of the public
hearing the Department's interaction
with the statatory section is relatively
light we don't get a lot of calls uh
questioning it or asking about its
meaning or its interpretation by and
large typically when the department is
hearing from the public about this
particular provision it's coming from
employers who are um kind of inquiring
can I do this um and I'm sorry I'm
Danielle Albert I'm the Deputy
Commissioner for the Department I just
launched into answering your question so
my apologies for the lack of uh
introduction um you know I think the
statutory language right now is clear
whether you're looking at the $300 or
the $3,000 language that there's a cap
there's a limit to the amount that the
employer is supposed to be paying out
right now it's 300 you're proposing
3,000 um anything in excess of that it's
a good question you know it might be one
that's worth the department researching
a little bit I'm not that familiar with
intest toy proceedings or the probate
proceedings are not intimately familiar
enough to say whether or not there's an
interplay there between the two statutes
that if you're going in advance of that
amount does the whole thing have to go
over or or is it only the amount in
excess of I think certainly it would
seem the way that the current language
is structured anything in excess of
would be steered towards the probate
proceeding
um and if there's a proper demand of the
payment uh from the person who is asking
the employer to make the payment then
the amount would be kept at the ceiling
that the statute has set um do you read
that the same way attorney McGrath
that's actually pretty much how I
testified before um with very little
knowledge of the probate system you can
have anything in excess if that's
allowed can be put towards the estate so
um I I'm reading it the same way that
Deputy Commissioner is all right and
just to be clear I think I understood so
the question is not what happens to the
excess but what happens to what's not an
excess if it is an excess so I'm owed a
million dollars on this massive sales
commission and I
and um that's all and that's another
question so that's all going to probate
so can I go in and say give me 3,000
right now or does the rest of the
language the way it says that in the
absence of actual notice of dependency
appr probate proceedings
mean that you shouldn't be giving me any
of and to be clear I'm I'm now
pretending to be not the dead employee
the in other words it is that it it
sounds like to me the way I read it the
way it's written is you can't give
somebody even some money if there's a
probate proceeding that should be
handling it I think if if it if it's
underway and that that also that that
language pendency of probate proceedings
might make a difference whether the
employer is triggering it because
there's now this big amount of money
that says well this is going to have to
go to probate versus the probate has
already begun for another reason in
which
case if it's already begun the employer
can't turn over anything if it hasn't
begun the employer can turn over up to
$3,000 and then the the rest goes over
or does this say you know what it's
either it's either probate or it's not
probate and if it's not
probate
then as long as the amounts doe are
under
$3,000 you can go with
it but if it is probate then everything
goes through the probate process I think
that's a fair reading under the rules of
statutory construction um if it is okay
with the committee I would wouldn't mind
taking it back to just digest I think it
really and I'm not trying to sound
grossly lawyerly over it I think it
depends on the placement of the commas
and what it's modifying um I think
that's accurate that if there is in the
absence of notice of the pendency of a
probate proceeding I.E if that has been
brought forward probate um if not then
there's a a ceilinged amount that can be
paid out without the letters of test
testamentary or administration of the
following following the list of deed
that are set forth in the
intestin
laws which I'm St under the current
language under the current language that
I'm looking at right now um so I think
that reading you know that reading I
believe is accurate again our
interaction with an application of it is
so limited because it does not come up
as an Enforcement issue for the
Department um so if you're okay with
that I wouldn't mind taking a slightly
close closer look and then perhaps
following up in writing and just
verifying yes that's the application
and and we haven't scheduled this
executive session yet so we have plenty
of time to
get information from the department and
even if our subcommittee is done we can
use that to make further Amendment um
and I've got a question the
um I read that to mean it's a cap and
you get you can get your $3,000 no
matter how big the paycheck is um how
much bigger the paycheck is um the piece
that um I want to check on is the uh
lines five and six um the the current
language reads in the following order of
preference to The Descendants in
accordance with the laws of iny in
inest intestacy for the State of New
Hampshire and that's being replaced with
with payment made um the order of
distribution set forth in RSA 5 561
colon 1 and I did look at that um during
the hearing um I was a tad troubled by
it because it's um it's a very
uh it's not easy to follow uh
561 um and I was concerned that um I
think there was a comment made that
you'd have to be an expert in Probate to
do some of the stuff when I read 56 I
said yeah you'd have to be and I'm
trying to figure
out is that if that's the way way it's
always been then I guess that's the way
it's always been and I have
no I have some concerns but I guess I
can live with leaving at the way it is
but I don't know if the current phrase
is equivalent to the proposed
phrase well I'm not an expert in the
laws of intestacy either and you do have
to be a specialized uh practician to go
into any type of a state and probate if
you're going to be any good at it um but
I did take a look a little bit at
5611 and um it it requires a a lot of
help trying to understand uh so the
breakdown what I think I'd like to do is
take a look and see whether or not this
basically mirrors the same thing and
it's just shortening the distribution
schedule by just stating the statute as
opposed to stating following the laws of
intestacy which could could be 561 is
that it it it would be best to take a
look at it because that is not my area
of practice and and I believe Deputy
Commissioner admitted the same um it
would be best to take a look at it to
see whether or not basically we're
replacing one um line with another
that's exactly the same the only thing
that I would say I'm sorry no no I'm
sorry the only thing that I would say is
that if it turns out and again I would
like to take a look at it but if it
turns out that
5611 actually ref refers you exactly to
the section that describes uh
testamentary uh progression airs and
things like that it might be easier to
look at right knowing what the statutory
uh reference is as opposed to just the
language that was in it before yeah
because B basically an employer might
just uh read that not really know quite
what it means and say I just I guess we
just give it all to the wife if it all
turns out to be exactly the same having
that reference makes them do a little
extra work to make sure that what
they're doing is correct I mean but the
but the average employer probably will
freak out when they read
561 um but uh and to the sponsor um did
OS come up with that idea all on their
own no they were prompted by me and I'll
go back uh Deputy Commissioner you were
the one who sent the email suggesting we
look at it and if I recall part of the
problem was that employers looked at
words like
intestacy and letters of testamentary or
of administration and pendency of
probate and they said I don't know what
I'm looking at and that that how this
got flagged was the number of calls that
you got on this so this was actually my
second draft I had already done the top
part and I was thinking boy that it says
with the laws of intestin intestacy for
the State of New Hampshire well surely
those laws are written down somewhere so
so I asked OSS can could you refer to
those by reference rather than by
description so a it's it's clear what we
mean and B that someone who doesn't
understand what this language is can go
and look at up and so OSS thinks okay so
they they they identify 561 as the the
laws of intestines right so um now we
just want to know if they're right right
that could use a second opinion and if
if it turns out that this the two aren't
equivalent my intention was to make it
exactly equivalent replace it not in
function but with clearer language for
the
average employer the law is not clear
language and the law is not clear but
the point is you have to follow the law
such as it is it is what it is yeah um
and then for the record um
I did a calculation
and if you make the Assumption which and
it is an assumption that um someone is
being paid um
bi-weekly um and that one of those
bi-weekly checks is um what the employer
is trying to pass on to somebody a
$33,000 um um payroll would would be um
someone who was earning approximately
$78,000 um which to me
sounds okay um you know somebody who's
earning about you know under
$100,000
um and and you know at least $3,000 is
worth thinking about I suspect that
people don't bother with the 300 um the
employers don't perhaps don't know about
it and don't do it um but once you get
to 3,000 I think it's it's it's worth
having it's a chunk of a funeral expense
um and
um I'm okay with 3,000 as a dollar
amount and the other thing that I looked
at again to to gut check the
3,000 is what that is relative to the
average wage in New Hampshire and it's
um for it's like three and a half weeks
I guess whether you're doing the mean or
the median is is closer to three or or
closer to three and a half depending on
which average you use but again that
tells me
that the bulk or let's say 2/3 of wage
earners would have either a weekly or a
bi-weekly check covered under the
3,000 and to me that felt right that it
gets most of the wage earners covered um
and it's only when you're in that upper
portion that um You' run into the
cab
I've been involved with two probate
cases where I was the executive and I do
a lot of probate why don't you turn that
on in case people are going to watch the
video the video I don't know they
probably are recording
us uh I've been executive of two
Estates and I do a lot of probate stuff
in my job and I can tell you that it
takes a good two or three weeks if not
more sometimes a month and a half the
time someone passes away and you deal
with the issues at hand of dealing with
the person and the family um and then
you have to go to probate even if their
will says it won't be probated you have
to at least go to a probate judge to
have them look at the will that says it
will not be
probated because of the Fairbanks case
of 30 40 years ago when someone took
judge Fairbanks took off of everybody's
money um they usually make you post a
bond in order to post a bond Bond even
if it's a minimum $33,000 bond which
only cost $100 but it's what most judges
make you do uh someone has to apply for
that someone has to be financially
creditworthy to get the bond we've had
situations where the executive listed in
the will or the uh some other family
member does not qualify have to go back
so you're talking six weeks eight weeks
then the the the the the lawyer has to
be engaged and that's going to cost a
thousand dollar or whatever so
I'm not so concerned about when you say
well what's the line of who's going to
get what okay uh because that $3,000 is
not going to be part of any anyone's
bequeaths or anyone's will uh
instructions that's going to take care
of what it takes to get through the
court system through probate and God
forbid if you don't have person doesn't
have any money to bury them or to
cremate them or anything else so I'm not
overly concerned concern with the 3,000
someone saying and being overly
concerned with um who's going to get
what percentage based on whatever the
will says because trust me
$3,000 um is going to have to go to
those other expenses associated with it
and if you don't have any money which
I've had these cases before where
someone says we don't have any money we
can't pay you the100 $500 for the bond
we can't even pay the attorney to get
them until we get some money well you
can't get some money until you get the
attorney and the bond and go to the
court so sometimes it's it's uh you know
the cart before the horse and
um so I'm okay with the
$3,000 you're not suggesting that $3,000
will go to probate
though no it'll have to be dealt with in
the Probate Court it has to be in the
first um when it comes to the
um when you have to fill out um
inventory thank you the inventory
paperwork has the assets and liabilities
but what this what this says is that
before um there's a notice of pendency
of probate proceedings the 3,000 can be
paid out so the way I read this is you
get your $3,000 check without even going
anywhere near probate and I'm saying
that's good okay because you need that
to be able to start the probate case in
a lot of circumstances now that money
will have to be allocated in you know
that was received because it is an asset
so once you do the probate after you've
done the inventory and you have to start
doing the accounting of the income and
the expenses yeah it'll show up there
okay uh but I I heard it concerned about
well you
know the favorite son gets uh 50% and
the unfavored son gets 25 and and the
whatever really unfavored son only gets
25 of that $33,000 trust me that's not
going to you know I don't think those
those fights are going to happen because
there's all the other things that are
much more important that have to be
dealt with than someone getting a the
quest of
aate the trick will simply be somebody
figuring out with
561 who's supposed to get the money in
accordance with
561 um
and that might be the first task of the
attorney that they're eventually going
to have to hire um and then the attorney
will take the
$3,000 yes and that was in
representative kill talked to um I think
with multiple people and that was one of
his comments that the probate's going to
cost you the $3,000 anyway uh one of the
fallbacks that initially I was I was
concerned about and when we did this as
a study committee years ago we had
somebody gets it wrong they they look at
that list they pick the wrong person
they give it to
a um an ex-girlfriend when it should
have gone to the dog da and to me the
fall back on that is that the employer
is not obligated to pay out 3,000 you
can't just show up at an employer and
say I'm the Man son give me my check
it's still the employer
May engage in the the process allowed
here or may say have uh an attorney
contact my attorney so I don't and we'll
deal with it through probate to me
back so the employer could just say I'm
not paying out anything it's going to
probate right I don't get you folks
agree with
that I I would agree with that there is
a May in there it's not a Shia okay so
if the employer can't figure it out he
can just say I'm hands
off all
right we know
thank you Mr chairman um what
protections do the employer have given
the fact that we're in 275 which is
employee protections for a wage claim
from a beneficiary you didn't pay on
time um you owe this we don't have we
want access to all his employee files we
want this we want that and
then this says may the employee says no
they go to you now the employer has to
the cost of his attorney this that and
the other thing
to yeah I think the interaction could
potentially come up in two different
ways you know one you would have the
scenario perhaps where
the person the the the um dependent
who's seeking the monies is perhaps
trying to file a wage claim asserting
some kind of right under
27547 um I think that that is something
the department could schedule in here
and the analysis is going to have to
flow from the facts that are presented
over the course of that case was there a
proper demand and then analyzing the
language as it relates to May and if
it's a May and it's not a sh and there's
sufficient justification there that the
employer doesn't have the obligation
then the order could be that they're not
obligated to pay it the other
interaction would be through the
Inspection Division if it somehow came
up in the course or context of it a
complaint you know if a um a dependent
called and is complaining I we you know
I I didn't get paid or it didn't get
paid in
full if the amount didn't get paid up to
the ceiling or didn't get um I would say
if the amount didn't get paid up to the
ceiling you could be looking at I don't
think it's like a violation of 27547
itself it's a violation of the failure
to make payment of wages but again you'd
have to look at that language relative
to May and in interacting with the
employer interacting with the
complainant and taking in whatever
information they have the determination
would be made as to whether or not they
were due or not and again I do think you
have to look at that language of May but
I think it depends on the scen on the
scenario on some level you know what was
said if the employer said yep you made
proper demand we're going to go ahead
and do that um and only pays half of it
or doesn't doesn't make the payment in a
timely manner that could have
interactions with other sections of the
statute so if the employee is salaried
employee let's just say and they don't
show up to work for two or three days
and you know it's their bi-weekly drop
in their direct deposit account and
somebody shows up the day after it's
deposited into says we want to get his
full pay well he hasn't been there for
two weeks we just paid him his last
paycheck you're on your own is there a
wage claim against that under
this scenario yeah I think that it would
again it would
depend one of the things that the
department encourages employers and
again it's primarily employers who call
with questions about this particular
provision is verifying like that you're
paying the correct person the scenario
you're talking about if I understand
correctly is more so the direct deposit
has gone maybe the employer is not aware
that the person is deceased um you know
I don't know what's in that bank account
that may ultimately end up getting
wrapped up as part of the appropriate
process because it's sitting with some
other asset that's um you know one if it
was paid pre request by the dependent of
the person is it now going to be wrapped
up in assets that are going to get swept
in with the probate um I think that
again somebody could try to articulate a
claim but whether or not it's going to
be successful is going to depend on the
timing of of when payment was made what
kind when the demand was made or when
the request was made what the employer's
response was I mean I think employers do
have to be cautious uh when making
payments because if you pay the wrong
person you know oh you're telling me
you're the person's spouse and I think
you know per my research or asking my
attorney or however they went about
checking the in intestacy I'll say it
wrong statute to determine who's who's
the right person to pay but I didn't
verify who that person was and now I
paid a cousin um has the payment been
made it has not you know so if the
cousin comes or the the dependent who is
entitled comes forward and says hey I
want the payment and the employer is
like oh I've already paid it out you
haven't paid the right person you know
so has the payment actually been made
and I think there are other steps the
employer has to go through to try to
recoup that money from the person who
actually wasn't entitled to it they want
to get it
back
um want to go
on now
that in the context of some of these
questions about what can go wrong that
the existence of such a law is probably
more protective to the employer than
obligatory on the employer and why I say
that is so if this law didn't exist the
labor department would take no position
on what happened when somebody showed up
and asked for a check of any amount from
an employer to me the existence of this
law gives the employer sort of a
presumption of I considered this request
I looked at the law I followed the law
to the letter
and that's all I can do um do you and
it's it kind of flips maybe the intent
we've been talking about which is to get
the money to the person but it seems to
me this also has an effect of saying
here are the parameters employer that
you work in and if you do
that hopefully that's going to be okay
for you does that make sense I I think
that does make sense um I think that's a
fair way of of coloring it if the
section did not exist at all and there's
money that's then outstanding and I'll
perhaps let attorney mcra correct me if
I'm in if I'm wrong on the application
but if if the final paycheck is owed
time was worked the money is owed this
provision doesn't exist setting the
ceiling for which some form of the wage
can be paid to a designated
individual I think it would then become
part of what gets swept up within the
whole probate process um I don't know
how the department would go through
necessarily and say oh you're you're
required under other sections of 275 to
pay a dependent in the absence of
something from a court saying this is
the executrix or executor or the person
who's allowed to take care of Affairs of
deceased keep keep
on so in relations to
a I don't want to say violation but if
there was an an inspection and this was
found okay you didn't pay this employee
within the designated time even though
he was deceased would that be a
violation to the employer for not paying
27547 it potentially could be again I
think it would depend on on the scenario
it's possible in certain scenarios it
could
be all right we're still in two we're
still in 275 How could an employer make
a payment to somebody that's not their
employee
um but you mean if this provision didn't
exist well it says May so I I want to
know what protections there is you know
we've talked about you know wife
daughter cousin whatever right what
authorizes them under 275 to pay
somebody other than an employee I think
you would have to look at the two
Provisions in conjunction with one
another so if the
um and again one the Department's never
cited or had had the issue come up so
I'm trying to H hypothetically think
about the type of scenario where it
could potentially come up if there were
a request from the dependent to make the
payment and and I think it would come up
more in the context of the employer made
maybe a partial but didn't fulfill the
full ceilinged amount uh so 300 or 3,000
whatever the dollar amount was and
didn't make the the full payment um but
was oper ating under
27547 it could potentially rise to the
level of a violation of not making the
timely payment when you're reading the
two in conjunction with one another or
making the payment in when you look at
the two in conjunction with one another
think if the interaction was that the
you know the Department's engaging with
the employer and the employer is
pointing to that but it's a May or you
know it's it's we've got notice of a
probate I don't know that that I don't
believe that would rise to the level of
evaluation but those are factors that
the department would have to consider in
acting with the employer about what had
happened correct but I don't
under 275 there is no provision to make
that payment to someone else other than
the
employee that's right as an employer
reading that I can't just go and pay the
daughter his residual checks with the
exception of the section 47 which does
allow for it if the again looking at
that language of May but I think section
47 does authorize in these Limited in
these types of circumstances for the
employer to make payment again it's not
necessarily the full pay check if the
paycheck is in excess of what the
statutory amount is but it's creating
the mechanism by which somebody other
than the employee can get paid in these
circumstances okay so the so the
employer goes ahead and deposits their
entire weekly check un unbeknownst to
the employer
um and a wage claim is made saying you
because because you didn't follow this
particular and give us the $3,000
outside of the his direct deposit into
his account which we have no access
to would the employer be on the hook for
that so let me just to make sure I
understand the scenario quickly so I'm
sorry forgive me for if I'm being
repetitive employee got paid or the
dependent got paid the employee so I
have an employ let's say I have an
employee he gets paid weekly you know he
dies on a Thursday his check goes in on
Friday yep the following week There's No
doesn't show up y so he's not entitled
to a paycheck right they show up and say
we want his last paycheck while he was
deposited on bah blah baah prior to
notification of the employer that the
employee is now deceased I think in the
that instance based on that scenario if
I'm understanding the hypothetical
correctly the payment has been made it's
now sitting in the account that was the
employees account it was made on in the
time man time means and manner is
specified by Statute after that payments
occurred somebody dependent is coming
forward saying oh I'm trying to exercise
Options under Section 47 of the
statute I think there's a good argument
there payment has been made whatever's
sitting in that account whether it's the
sole paycheck or it's a million dollars
plus the paycheck um is more likely than
not going to get swept in with the sort
of wrap up of the of the person's estate
um and if it goes through probate goes
through probate it may very well be
swept up within the probate process okay
just make sure that there's protections
for the employer if they're following to
and then this is coming up at a later
dat so they don't have to incur attorney
cost and and possibly hearing and
everything else to make sure that hey
you know what we did what we're supposed
to do as an employee we don't want to
get into all this and I'm gonna I think
attorney mcra wanted to add something to
that so if it's okay so in the current
language of Statute which doesn't look
like it's being altered at all it also
says making proper demand so looking at
the request let's say that the cousin
comes the week after the death the
employer just then is notified of the
death is that proper demand and I don't
know the answer to that question but
that can be something that can be um
dealt with at a hearing or it could be
dealt with at probate um if the employer
has notice of the death prior to the
issuance of that final paycheck I think
that's where we are looking at the May
or the shall and the due diligence
requirement for the employer comes into
play but I think proper demand can be
defined in any way that makes sure that
it complies with the statute and if
there's no money to be had because in
your scenario representative avalani
there would be no money the person's
paid and there's they didn't come to
work the next week so therefore there is
no money owed therefore based upon the
statute there's no money to
pay I have a follow up to that oh now
say there was wages due beyond that say
it was there was you know vacation time
or sick time or something there was you
know acred and needed to be paid out
what if that is also automatically done
given that you know say the employer has
a three-day termination policy no show
policy you terminated you they paid all
their benefits to this account they're
done and you know the employer was
notified the week after again same thing
you know after the window that the money
has been deposited would they get in
trouble for not following this because
descendants
I think that well first of all I think
you're also bringing um representative
kahill's bill into this as well that was
discussed earlier today so could I just
had to make a little bit of a a
statement on that um but I think it
really comes down to the same thing that
Deputy commissioner's been talking about
which is there's the the recourse is a
potential hearing there is the notice
Provisions there's the proper demand
Provisions that are in all of this
whether or not the employer actually has
a practice or policy policy sorry I'm
bringing that back in a practice or
policy to pay that out automatically
even on a three-day no call no show um
you have to look at all the evidence and
and take it from there um has the
employer done is due diligence really
Forefront and this will be it okay like
I said so if the employee doesn't show
up they cause for demand after
everything has already been paid out
into his account per 275 that we would
follow up until that point is the
employer protected for making those
deposits from going through a hearing
and everything else through a wage claim
because we didn't follow this
piece let me see if I understand that
because it it's I'm not sure that I'm
again so an employeer has a policy 3
days no call no show you're you're
terminated all your benefits whatever is
paid out boom boom boom they show up
afterwards the employee or the family
the family shows up after bearing demand
upon whatever is left over okay with
with and then they go after the employer
stonewalls and says we paid them we
haven't heard from anything we don't
want to get involved they go to the
department and say okay well
everything's in his account now we can't
we can't get it because they they should
have sent it to us according to what
we're doing here today but want make
sure there's a there's protections for
the employeer not to incur additional
cost attorneys fees time and everything
else the department is just going to say
you did what you're supposed to do under
275 by paying your employee following
your policies but we're going to have a
hearing because they brought in a wage
claim and we we don't know this is very
because it's a May instead of a shall or
this or that we want to make sure that
we're clear going forward that there's
no additional cost to that employer for
following the rules of proper payments
relating in 275 as we do on a daily
basis okay I believe I understand the
question correct me if I'm wrong Mike
one question back to you before I say
anything though is did the employer have
notice that the employee was deceased
prior to issuing all those payments of
the PTO or whatever it is that they were
entitled to by the three call no
three-day no call noow was the employer
notified that the employee was deceased
prior to the issuance of that pay let's
just say no for this time then the
employer should be protected based upon
the language of this with no notice that
the employee has been deceased which
could then potentially put it into
probate the employer should also be
protected by the fact that they were
just issuing payment the way their
practice and policy was pursuant to
whether it's an employee manual or just
simply practice and policy the employee
didn't show up for work the employer had
no idea as to why the employee didn't
show up it may have to be addressed um
at the Department of Labor through a
hearing but there are Protections in
there I didn't didn't know he was dead I
didn't know and then proper demand was
not made until after all payments were
issued and after the employer was
notified of the deed okay if
I may uh clarify a little bit part of
what I'm hearing is and I think it's not
just this it's the way any wage claim
would work there's never a black and
white right it anything
one side could say I want I disagree
with what you just told me I want a
hearing and and that's kind of what
you're saying here you can't guarantee
that given these circumstances this is
how it would end up because that hearing
process is part and parcel of how any
issue is resolved right am I I think yes
I think that's correct representative
seaworth um you know when parties
request a hearing they're putting
forward that there's some kind of
dispute but the resolution of that
dispute or whether or not there's even
Merit to the dispute is something that's
addressed over the course of that uh
hearing process whether it's done
through um prelimin preliminary written
correspondence and we see a lot of that
in wage claims you know an employee
asserts a claim an employer will respond
and say well that's not the case because
X Y and Z I don't think you should
schedule this hearing and it can be
assessed in weighed at that point and if
the determination is okay the threshold
has not been met to have a hearing it
maybe not go forward on that basis more
often than not they do go to the hearing
the parties have the opportunity then to
present all those pieces and exactly as
attorney mcra had outlined it's
something the employer could raise and
that's where the determination would
ultimately come from um so I don't know
if the question is in part would it
Stave off you know a hearing from being
scheduled I don't know that the
department could say that with any
certainty again would kind of depend on
what was filed what the responses were
um but it could dictate it could dictate
the course of the
outcome thank you represent right I know
Don's got his hand up as well um the um
guess a couple points I think being
U directed to the word may um that
that's that basically um addresses most
everything if you accidentally pay the
employee and someone comes asking for
the money May gets you out of it um
because basically it says you may do it
you may not um and so essentially I I
because I was uh concerned about the
issue raised during the hearing of um uh
automatic um uh payroll
um direct deposit direct deposit thank
you um um because I I mean I bet that
would happen almost all the time because
most people are paid by direct deposit
now and um unless somebody says stop
that money is going to get dumped into
the the account um and if the if someone
shows up and and gives their notice
they'll simply say sorry there's no
money be and and I was not required to
give this to uh to anybody um and it it
it's in Probate it it'll come to you but
just no time soon and I guess my other
point is if I was in the position of
advising somebody on this statute
I'd say optt out to the employer because
basically once you start writing checks
now you've created a potential liability
if you simply say I'm going
to I'm not going to do this I mean I'm
I'm sure some employers are just going
to wanting to be kind-hearted and take
advantage of this opportunity to help a
family of an employee and so on but
um it seems like a better idea to Simply
say I know I could but I'm going to
to and and I think looking at the
current iteration of the language and I
don't believe this section is changing
um as well it's wages that are due so in
the scenarios where deposit has been
made and it's pre- notification of death
it's preoper Demand by the deant or the
The Descendants or deant or The deant
Descendants um and I think attorney
McGrath had highlighted this our wages
due at that point if they've already
been paid right um I think think this my
reading of the statute and its current
iteration at least is it's intended to
address those scenarios where there's
still some form of payment that's
paid um
thanks representative suin just asked
two of the questions I was going to
ask bring up the third one is all this
bill does is change the amount and
clarifies another statement everything
else is already in the
law am I correct in analyzing that I
believe that is correct yes thank you
and I guess the Counterpoint to that is
because it's
$300 you ju you just don't have the
experience that you might get if it if
we raise it to a more reasonable amount
so that's part of I think why some
people have these hypotheticals is well
what if employers actually start using
it will will we see something that we
haven't seen before sure and and to be
clear I I don't know that the department
has a good sense or can with any
certainty say are employers using this
or not using it things issues come to
the Department's attention you know when
somebody's got a technical question am I
obligated to do this is there a law out
there that addresses this somebody asked
me about it I don't know how it works
can you guide me through the process I
think that's a lot of the Department's
interactions um you know or through a
complaint process I'm complaining
because I I asked for wages I wasn't
paid in time workers comp complaints
whatever it may be when things are
running well or if parties are not
having disputes or don't have questions
that that does not necessarily land with
the department so I don't know to what
degree employers are or are not engaging
with the statutory provision I don't
know that we have a good sense if the
dollar amount changes will that increase
contact will contact stay you know
relative the same
um
but so it's a it's a bit of a it is a
bit of a question if the dollar amount
goes out will that increase uh contact I
I do not know it's it's certainly
possible and it's fair to raise those
questions I think in contemplating
whether or not you make the
change my other concern is
uh it was about fif 50 years since you
they had the
$300 and and bringing it up to $3,000
how many more years will that stay there
you know that's so maybe if we put the
word by-weekly instead of a dollar
max no I have thoughts I I for one would
prefer the dollar amount and if it gets
stale um
somebody someday ought to do this but I
guess based on all the discussion we're
having I think having it uh um
potentially Ian because there were
issues raised about um whether
somebody's not on a regular payroll
whether on commission or something like
that I think putting a limit of 3,000
because I'm sitting here thinking I
don't want any higher than
3,000 um it should be higher than 300
3,000 seems fine but um if you if you
start talking real money people are
going to get more and more excited so I
I just soon leave leave it at a dollar
amount
and let it um you know basically put it
on the department to bring this to our
years any follow up on that okay we
know not a hypothetical question but do
we need
this I was thinking that too I I think
that's a question that's appropriate for
the committee and the and the commission
to answer um I from the Department
Department's perspective it's in the law
it's one that we can administer the
amendment as written we believe that we
can administer um our interactions with
it as noted are are compared to other
interactions under other statutory
Provisions are are smaller um not not a
lot of contact I'm not aware of and I
checked with our Inspection Division
before coming over today I'm not aware
of viations ever being found or at least
not within recent years not that I'm
aware aare of I'm not aware of wage
claims that have been brought under this
provision or addressing this provision
and again questions seem to be oriented
when they come to the department from
employers uh around I want to make
payment because I had a person pass am I
allowed to do that and you know can I
give it to this
person
so go ah could could in the absence of
this you would still be able to
administer payment of wages to the
employe deceased employee according to
policy and
procedure listed in
275 within seven days or 14 days within
eight days or 15 days yes and if I
understand in part what you're asking is
if this provision did not exist what
would it perhaps change they would
remove the mechanism by which the
dependence uh or what the the The
Descendants is what they say in the
statute but those next in line folks of
being able to to make the request and
get the payment um outside of that
probate process so again this section
does create a mechanism by which someone
other than the employee specified
persons is able to access some of wages
that are due not the whole amount if
it's an excess of 300 or 3,000 whatever
the dollar amount is there's a mechanism
whereby an employer can make that
payment um I think if the section does
not exist that mechanism would not exist
anymore thank you and I've thought about
that question my myself and I
think there's another answer to that so
this is written to be permissive this is
when you can give this money if we
repealed it in its entirety
though it if you look at the Department
of Labor wage and
hour laws and rules they're really not
permissive they're prohibitive that this
if everything's fine and nobody has
complaints it doesn't come to you it
comes to you because somebody did
something that they weren't supposed to
so I think you also have to read this is
what is it telling you not to do and it
tells an employer that you cannot give
more than
$3,000 in in uh to uh dependent but that
was wrong descendant I think it says um
it tells the employer you cannot turn
over this money if there's already a no
a dependency of probate
proceedings and I think
that becomes
important if you repeal it what you're
also changing is you're opening up
anything can happen anybody can come in
come into an employer and ask for
anything and the employer has to decide
on their own well what I don't know what
to do what am I going to
do the department will now have no
opinion what's what soever if someone
comes and
complains and says I
think this employer did it
wrong you have you have very little way
of of adjudicating that because there
there now is no longer a set of
rules that they could have followed and
so that's my
concern with and I thought about that
too does all this complic could we just
repeal it now you know all the
complication goes away and I think that
in practice that could open up more of
all the issues that you're talking
about than exist with the law in place
Brian yeah
um kind of losing my train of thought
here um oh I know what it was If an
employer became aware of this and they
get a um uh a proper demand uh from a uh
from the family um might just be the
family in general and that employer came
to the department and said we can't
figure out who to give the money
to would you
help that is a very good question the
department would help by providing
guidance on what the statutory require
or what the what the statute sets forth
but if what they're asking the
department is tell me who the right
descendant is the Department's not
really in the right entity nor in
position to necessarily know that so we
might Point them towards resources um we
might Point them towards the in in I
can't say it in testy statute we might
suggest that they seek guidance if
that's needed um I think that would be
bordering potentially on some form of
legal advice because you're giving an
opinion at that point about oh yes it's
the spouse it's the son it's the
daughter um when you when you said
resources what does that mean uh legal
resources we you know can we will refer
to other agents other agencies in
certain scenarios if the ideas you need
to maybe talk to the free legal service
there are free legal services out there
that will give um you know legal advice
on short-term basis is that people are
able to access um pointing them towards
whatever resource we may have available
to help them sort out that piece of the
question but I don't believe that the
Department's role and we are not
currently saying oh it is this person we
do try to um counsel the employer on
make certain again there is a
requirement here that it's got to follow
the laws of the anesty of the State of
New Hampshire there's an order to those
things you want to make certain that
it's the right person before you make
payment because have you if you go make
payment to the wrong
person did the payment actually happen
whether it goes through the probate or
doesn't go through the probate so make
sure it's the right person if your
intent is to do this but we would not be
making a determination or giving them an
opinion on oh this is the right person
and going back to the point of do we
need this
um if what the person would really need
to interpret
561 is uh a legal
opinion um the legal opinion may very
well take a long enough period of time
that by the time it comes the probate's
underway and so now the employer can't
pay it anyways or has already paid it to
the account or whatever but you know in
order to stay within timelines they
would need to move that money um but if
they if it can't be figured out who to
pay it to then they will simply have to
um pay it to the estate or the the
employer the deceased employees account
and uh be done with it so I'm not sure
if this is functionally uh something
well thank you and I I do have that
question myself things have changed
quite a bit since
1963 when maybe people were going to the
cash window and and getting money to get
to get their money at the end of the
week um and now
everything almost everybody at our
number 98% of people are doing direct
deposit
um is there even room in that process if
you are paying wages on time they get in
there and say oh something happened
we've got to do things differently or is
it almost all of the time going to fall
into the direct deposit and be in that
account to be dealt with by and and one
further
point this is not something that we are
not fixing a problem that was presented
to us this is we are fixing a problem
that we dug
up um and no one has ever come to us and
said this is a real problem we can't
live with uh this way in New Hampshire
we've got it this needs to be fixed
um the uh the study committee found it
thought it was a little bit odd that it
was only 300 bucks there's a reason for
that um but it's not like someone has
said this isn't working and the question
for us is will this work and with direct
deposit I'm not sure it will the money's
going to be in the account by the the
time the request
comes and in response to that does it
work in my opinion it still works and it
it's something you said earlier that
may might any employer if they call
their lawyer they'll say don't touch it
just put it in Let It Go through direct
deposit and to me that's an option an
employer can say I
don't this is this is above my pay grade
I don't want to get into that and
likewise 99% of the time lawyer advice
to that end or not the money is going to
do what it's going to do and this
provision would never get invoked does
that mean it's a problem to allow it to
be invokable I I don't think so
um on the other hand and this goes back
to what would happen if you
repeal if you really want this law to
kind of go away because you think it's a
relic of the past maybe the best thing
to do is not touch it because right now
$300 almost nobody can even affect that
and as inflation arose that away
it the law eventually just says you
can't ever ask for money directly it
always has to go through probate
because the amount that applies under
here is so small but and I I suppose
that's another thing is amended to just
say you can't do it um but
that's I think it would be if that's the
if that's really what we're after it
would be safer to leave it untouched and
course know so we just take the dollars
what after demand be paid with payment
made in the order of distribution set
forth 561 call and one take out
everything
else so you think that amount that
someone could demand should be
unlimited there should be no they
shouldn't it should go either write into
the it should go to the employee or to
his
probate if it goes the employee goes to
probate right so either way that the
employer is covered by not making a
mistake by following the May or no man
so and this is why I'm unclear the
reference to RSA 561 colon one says what
you do if there is no will and there is
no
probate if there there's a will or
probate and that's what this not being a
lawyer I'm probably not entirely right
about this but a phrase letters of
testamentary or of
administration as far as I can tell not
being an expert those are the results
those are the orders that come out of
probate um and one has to do with with
the execution of the will and the other
has to do with with the
Probate Court saying there was no will
order
so that keeping the last sentence that's
telling you how to give the money out on
your own without any guidance and what
you're saying is you don't don't want
that at all so it would be the last
um and I I don't know quite how you
would reward it that you would change
the mate to a may not I guess no we we
can probably get rid it should be just a
sentence now now that I'm hearing what
you're saying um with the direction of
the department
to in the event of the death of an
employee wages due to the decedent shall
be paid according to
274 within the 8 days or 14 days
after they're deceased to be you know or
or policies and procedures relating to
the
employment think that they would be paid
Into the Now deceased person's however
the deceased person was Prior getting
paid right that's what you're proposing
the only the only thing that may be of
value to look at is if it is now known
deceased does that affect and I don't
know the answer to this I'm not an
expert in in um wrapup of of Affairs or
or um after people are deceased what go
you know what goes to probate when how
that's triggered how long it takes so
forgive me on that part um if if
something comes forward and somebody's
either contesting the will or there is
no will or there is no probate we've got
a line of people looking to make claims
is that going to freeze up I don't know
if that freezes up the account or makes
makes it impossible for the how I think
you you'd have to look at how's the
employer going to make that payment if
something has uh been put forward and
there's disputes and it's not going
through probate and there's not a not a
will not sure how that would work to be
honest um it may not have any effect but
I think it's a piece to look at or to
consider if that's the change that
you're considering I I had a member
suggests to me that so suppose it's a
joint account that the checks are going
into and that joint account holder is
not entitled to any money under the will
or the probate could that potentially
by forcing that money the employer to
make that deposit and then be
distributed to the wrong person could
that actually put the employer on the
hook for misallocate
and I'm not trying to ask you to answer
it but it was it was kind of a different
way of looking at it we're kind of
assuming that in most cases if the money
just goes in direct deposit the system
that's intended to handle it would deal
with it but there are
those um kind of rare
cases where there is no direct deposit
that someone gets paid with a p for
check we bring up another bill that we
have or by cash or by or by cash right
and and so in that
case and I and I and I've said it before
but I'll repeat I think if you look at
when this was written that was probably
the norm not the exception now it's the
exception but it's not unheard of
that there could be an EMP employer
sitting there with cash they don't know
who to give it to um and if the deceased
employees wife came in to collect it it
would be very nice if they could just
say all right I'm done here it is
if I may um that appears to be what this
bill is trying to do is to make it so
that that employer can choose that
option right um the concern that I would
have and again you would have to you
really focus on probate law and
representative infantine obviously has
more experience in it than I do but the
concern that I would have is if the
employer has knowledge that this claim
or this employee is
deceased and still issues payment into
whether it's a joint account or not but
still issues payment into a bank account
or or um a or pay card or whatever it is
I think that that's more of a problem
when it comes to probating at what point
in time and representative infanti might
be able to answer this question better
at what point in time is the money does
it have to go into probate because the
person is no longer alive versus we've
always been putting it into his direct
deposit so that's what I'm going to do
even though I know he's
deceased so I I don't know the answer to
that question um and that might actually
trigger the requirement of a probate to
distribution normally everything
stops if you find out one of your
employees is deceased you're supposed to
stop direct
deposit because at that date it's no
longer the individual it's the
estate okay
um does that happen in real
life probably not in some circumstances
but technically that's what's supposed
to happen so that would still be um part
of the probate case as our all assets
the the the instantaneous time the
person no longer
exists
um again it can be accounted
for in the inventory and it can be
accounted for in the
um income the whatever quarterly uh
filings but my issue is the reason why
you have
this
flexibility is because by the time you
get this checked and by the time you set
up a checking account for the probate
and by the time you get the application
get a hearing date get the judge to
request a bond get all this
stuff people need the money and
um now what happens in a lot of
circumstances it's a spouse it's a joint
checking account it goes in there anyway
and and
happens um but technically if everyone's
following the law
Brian the employer really should
not provide any check anymore after the
person passes
away um to the direct deposit because
that person's no longer and they should
just hold that money until the directed
where to say correct and this this this
the reason for this bill probably the
reason for this law 50 years
ago
was to not have to wait for all that
stuff to happen and and so you know
someone had you know some of these
people they need they need that
right and and I think the amount before
they even get social security benefit
spous sping benefits even 50 years ago
$300 wasn't a huge amount of money um
and $3,000 today is not a huge amount of
money um and if an employer I mean
there's a lot of employers who really
get get busted up over the fact that
their employee passed away um and they
may want to do this even if there's some
risk involved um and
um
you know they just have to somehow and
it might be Rel in many instances it
might be relatively easy to figure out
who who who's entitled to the money um
and you might want to just verify that
you're doing it right with legal counsel
um and then cut the
check
um and to that if I read
uh 561 col one the first line is if the
deceased is survived by a spouse the
spouse shall receive so in that most of
the time it's very you don't have to go
down what's next if there is a spouse
then that's and and if it gets more
complicated that might be your trigger
right um I do and it as an if I'm an
employer so I'm getting ready to hit
approve on my payroll on Thursday night
and someone comes running in and I said
died how
much legal advice and bills am I taking
on by not hitting s so now I have this
money the monies do the employee but now
I can't I don't have an employee to send
it
to I don't know where to send it to the
estate because that hasn't been
established yet but that money was it
was due it's now
overdue um according to payroll laws it
almost seems like having an out where an
employer can unload that last bit of
money that is too small to really make
it worth fighting over but could be
really a mess for that employer if
they're waiting to be told what to do
with it it it seems like that's another
protection that this has to the employer
is saying if the money is small enough
and you know who to give it to you can
just issue the check and and you're done
now now somebody else is dealing with
problems again what's supposed to happen
and what does
happen um a vast majority have a spouse
sometimes you have a younger person that
a child who has no girlfriend boyfriend
spouse engagement or anything um I've
uh no one knew what to do would it then
go to the
parent yeah
actually
yes and then this has the next provision
is what happens if there is no surviving
issue or parent or spouse because that
was already then it goes to the entire
estate which basically puts it right
back in Pro
right I I think the goal of the original
bill was to try to Pro I could be wrong
but initially reading this the $300
amount was
there because if that's the only thing
the person had kind of a voids probate
for a paycheck um and that it provides
the employer an ability to pay someone
who comes comes to them and says look we
don't have any money can't even bury the
person you know and prob it's going to
take a month you know can you can you
give us can you give us a paycheck so we
can do whatever because any employer
normally would say I can't do that the
employer employee no longer exists
legally so it has to go to the
estate
um so you know it all depends how
formal these Estates are I mean some are
very informal they never even inform the
courts and the other spouse just takes
everything and and they have a death
certificate and if there's a mortgage or
whatever they deal with it that way so
you know you're talking and and loo I
don't like yours because you take
someone that makes $250,000 a year who
gets bonused out another $100,000 a year
and and at the end of the thing the guy
say okay his bonus at the end of the
year is another 100 Grand and so here's
$125,000 I think that's a little much
well you mean have a no number correct
oh just no number because it all comes
questions all come from the
employer so say we can make this easy
enough that an employer doesn't have to
call the do or engage legal council and
how to make the last
payment you know we can certainly cap it
but if it's wages due it's wages due
whether it's to their checking account
whether it's through their spouse or
whether it's through their estate and
with the employer
at holding that till they get would
would they would they be subject to a a
wage claim and B if they ever ever had a
you know inspection would they be could
they be fed for that I think after
they're due quite frankly I think this
gives the employer more of an out than I
know you were talking about protections
if I give the check and then some other
surviving person who has owed money or
or debtor uh can come after you
um I think this provides them protection
I know you're concerned about the
protection of them I think the law
allowing that provides the
protection especially if an insolvent
estate but I'm not a lawyer play one on
TV um let's put it this way someone
already decided the law was okay at $300
right 50 years
ago um but we have direct POS I
understand then have all the excess laws
but even direct deposit quite frankly
pressing that button as Brian example
that law allows that yeah because
technically being being what I know
about being the law on
probate person's dead you can't send it
to them this this allows the employer to
do
that so you got a husband a wife and a
joint checking account it's direct
deposit right technically the way I know
Pro B and get a lawyer is that you can't
do that as soon as that person dies that
that money has to go in the state so
where is that written for an employer to
follow I think by allowing that
$300 you're giving the employer the
ability to do that law says I can do it
for $3,000 I did it no but if you you're
supposed to pay the employee because
those those are wages do the employee
not after they die right but if you
don't don't know they're dead no if you
don't know they then it still gives you
right but I mean if it's I just want to
make sure that we're we're actually
coming bringing this law up to the times
and I I want to go back to something you
said you don't hear about this and why
don't you hear about it because if
nobody has an issue nobody's going to
come into the Department of Labor and
say I got the money that I was supposed
to get but I don't like the method by
which I was paid I think they gave me
too much in this check and not enough
nobody's going to come in and ask you to
adjudicate that so in terms of the
enforcement of this
law it's only going to kick in when
somebody comes in and
says this person did it wrong and and
this is what I this is why I think they
did it wrong and I want you to resolve
it
so I think that I think I'm answering
your question is you know who who
watches this stuff and the answer is
nobody unless
somebody complains that it was there's a
problem and that's why you don't have
the experience on this because are
people using this are they not who knows
nobody complains about the process is is
most mostly what you know well if you
have someone where kid doesn't like Mom
and mom doesn't like the kid and someone
passed away and someone makes a beef to
the complaint that they never should
have passed that money over because I
would I was entitled to it versus them
or some debtor is trying to say that and
if if one of the goofy things about
probate that stinks is if you pay money
out and they're not in
priority you have to sometimes executive
has to pay the money back so the money
goes to the right priority I just think
this provides an out it kind of gets a
rid of all that priority and everything
else priority is death
benefits lawyer
fees
debtors I I get all this useless stuff
that I really wish I didn't know I want
to unlearn some of the stuff I yes but
however if you're in indul I if you're
in there for an unrelated matter and you
come across this that an employee was
not paid on
time would this allow the employer some
protection to not get a fine from not
paying this employee on time because
hece or is this or am I look or should I
be looking somewhere else for that
exception for coverage for the employer
to say you know we found out he was
deceased before payroll went out we
don't know where it is it's sitting in
this account we want to pay them and you
come in and say well you didn't pay this
employee on time because you don't have
the right paperwork yet where where is
the department on that to say well we're
going to find you because you didn't pay
this employee on time according to 275
boom boom boom but over here it says you
may pay a separate amount to a
descendant upon proper notice you're
waiting for that proper
notice you know where I'm going with
this I I think I do and so again forgive
me if I misunderstood and jump in and
and clarify for me if I haven't
understood it you're talking about a
where the Department's already out
perhaps performing an inspection and it
looks like employee a has not been paid
on time so the question comes up what
happened with employee a right and the
employer comes back and and explains to
the department employee a passed we're
not sure how to pay them um again I
think you know inspections themselves
are also very fact dependent um the
section in
47 one gives the authorization to the
employer to make that payment but there
has to be the demand for it um again
we've never gone out as far as I am
aware of and cited this as a violation
or found a violation that stemmed from
this Arena um if if the department
interacted with the
employer and there hadn't yet been a
demand I'd have to look at how that
could potentially uh play out I mean
it's it it could be
construed there could be a potential
violation for not making payment on
time um because that is the requirement
in the other side 275 I'm not going to
remember the provision off the top of my
head you know that you've got to make
payment on the within within the
specified parameters as set forth by
Statute uh if there's a decedent who can
be paid and there's been a demand for
that payment again there's a May in
there and I think it kind of depends on
the scenarios about why you know what
happened with with the the May and also
if the employer is making efforts to try
to
pay the deceased person but probate or
something else has frozen the account or
made it there's some other law that's
interacting with that or there's
something that's happening where okay we
we're we we're holding it because
there's an operation or a mechanism
that's preventing us from paying I me
that's something the department has to
look at in determining whether or not
the violation occurred um or whether or
not it rises to the level of a violation
but if I'm stripping it down sort of
very very simplistically very black and
white and I don't think it is
necessarily that black and white could
it possibly rise to the vi violation it
potentially could um would that happen
in every
scenario I it would depend I I don't I
don't know that I could say yes or no I
think it would really depend on what
what's occurred and what was sort of
born out in the course of interacting
with the employer in the course of that
you so I I think we've discussed
this very well this afternoon and um
unless somebody has another aspect of
this that they want addressed I would
say our job now is to make the
recommendation to the committee a
recommended
motion
um with with a couple caveats the
department did say that they would um uh
take a closer look at the language um
immediately following the 300 $3,000 and
would just verify that um uh RSA 561 is
exactly what we think it
is so um I believe that uh
representative seaworth was actually
reading from his laptop
5611 read off what the order of um yeah
of test toy this actually the language
that you're Crossing out I would
question whether descendant is
appropriate if we're looking looking at
the orders of um an order from a probate
court it would go to as it says on 5611
from my recollection of what you read
off spouse
first child or issue second up to parent
after
that um and I'm not going any further
with that part I wouldn't even I'd be
hesitant to go that far because of the
way it's written it so the spouse that's
easy there's a spouse go spouse is in a
then it starts to go to what if there
aren't these other things and you've got
to read quite a bit so let's say it's a
child
um onea doesn't tell you to pay that
child it tells you what to do if there
is no child and so somewhere down there
I've got to read down to well is it the
only child or is it one of multiple
children
so from that standpoint for me it's very
complicated if it's not spouse
and I would I
think I understand why OS struck
him um and I think OS was trying to come
up with a a neutral way of of putting
that but you're correct the deant is not
necessarily the person who's going to be
specified at the bottom um deant may
have some legal
meaning to it that does not correspond
with when I start going down through
5611 whom I find is the is the
designated person uh thing
to to replace deant which may be a
legally loaded term with a
[Music]
non so just to be clear um what I'm
looking at is the word
descendant
so
this it's crossed off it's your
intention was to cross it off as part of
this bill um so that's where I'm saying
that I'm not sure that based upon what
you read in
5611 if descendant is even appropriate
in
2023 because it's basically saying that
the distribution if you were to leave
that language as is and not cross it
off is there possibly a concern with a
conflict with 5611 where actually the
first person to be paid if they exist is
descendant my point is is maybe 50 years
ago okay I see what okay now I get it
that this may have been intended to
override 561 co11 which by the way may
not have
existed I'm I'm going at
71 oh no there was 190 three there was
something so there was something there
but that that's I had never thought
about that was this intended to
override the law and not allow the
spouse to collect the money um if it was
a a child who came in and gosh I hope
not but you're right the word
descendant if you take it literally a
spouse or a
parent who might have precedence over a
child might not be a descendant under
the old language um to be honest if
that's true then that's another argument
for
striking the existing language and
replacing it with a reference to the law
as written and as may be amended in the
future um because yeah if that's true I
don't like it at all that it's will
follow state law
unless um really makes me uncomfortable
and then as it relates to the other uh
portion that the department was going to
follow up on specifically if there's
notice of a the pendency of the probate
proceedings is it the all or the all or
the nothing is by end of day tomorrow an
okay time frame that is is more than uh
uh rapid enough um what I would propose
to the committee is that we do um make
sure that any requests of the department
are are on the table before we leave I
am
comfortable finalizing our
recommendation in either case we want to
know those answers before we vote as a
committee but I it wouldn't change my
opinion as a member of the subcommittee
if you say yes or no or so um
tomorrow or or or this week
um is plenty we can have it for tomorrow
so I think that'll be a quick one for us
to follow up
on different that we're talking about
561 if that's stay if that's staying in
there and and the employer makes a
mistake in
paying follows that and says okay well
you're the spouse you're giving me this
paperwork yes goes to probate and the
spouse is only getting $1 out of the
will would the employer be on the hook
for paying out of order according to 561
would they now be let's say there's a
child would they now be have to pay the
child that wages due because they
misapplied that payment to a to a spouse
according to 561 by having this language
in here that talks about whether or not
there's any type of probate order and
I'm not going to repeat the ones that
tongue tias if there's any type type of
a probate order by having that in here
if there's no probate order at the time
of the distribution of those due
wages then if the employer follows 5611
and the spouse is present there's no
divorce they're still married um and
gives it to her and in the end she's
only entitled to $1 that's something
that's going to have to be addressed in
the Probate Court after that as far as
fixing it with the inventory and the
accountings that wouldn't be back to the
employer saying pay the wrong person and
again right just making just reading
brain to prot what happens if they give
this to someone complain I think allows
them to do
that they follow the
requested and then it's up to State not
deal again I said's
world most of the money from that $3,000
is go
toal
primary second primary is taxes lawyer
fees which is going to do expense or
taxes and and I just don't see that you
can't bury someone even appre for $2500
today so bury them out in the
back0 with the family grave site it's
still going to cost you some money so I
just don't see it this from a probate
standpoint using the priority of who
gets money
that
50,000
and I I agree too that the way this is
worded
um that it that it it will resolve that
issue not
complicated
um that's how I read that's how we read
and and I guess that's again somebody
in so somebody could come in for a
hearing right I I could say I'm the my
spouse I so I go in and I say could you
give me the three grand Yos and the
employer says no because I don't want to
I could go to the Department of Labor
and say I think they should have given
it to me and I think the reason they
didn't is because they don't have enough
money in their payroll account and
they're trying to cover for the fact
that they can't make wages and you would
hear you would hear that and you'd hear
the employer side of it and who knows
what you'd decide it would depend on all
the facts of that case
so to say can you assure us that when
this happens it will never go to a
hearing because the law covers it the
answer is no you can't give us those
assurances but we can imagine
reasonable
outcomes um that would never get to the
hearing or would be quickly resolved in
a preliminary hearing or or that sort of
thing so how do we get this there so we
don't have that so that we don't have
that so that it's not going to hearing
or no dispute could ever be brought up
about
it there's obviously going to be
outliers people that withhold it just to
hide behind this blah blah blah but for
a regular employer to not have to incur
a $1,500 lawyer bill because they don't
know what to do with
this which is cheap these
days that that's a fair question I think
that would require some additional
thought I don't know that that's one
that I'm able to answer um or spin or or
provide language for um off you know in
the immediate would that be part of what
you're asking for Mr
um think that's a
and other people can weigh in it's not
just me that seems like a lot of ask to
say you know how do we change the law to
make sure that the department always
denies request for hearings is that I
don't think that exists anywhere you
always will
entertain a request to say I think
there's a problem um I I don't think we
can legislate that Pro it it's the
essence of how you adjudicate things and
I don't think we can legislate that away
well it's it's like saying um how can
you stop people from suing each other
you can't no not I'm not saying that I'm
just saying so a regular person a
regular employer doesn't have to call
his attorney rack up a bill trying to
figure out who to pet that there at
least it's clear that so the department
can if they call the department the
department can give them at least some
guidance saying you you just do this
this and this having to rack up a legal
bill trying to figure out somebody's I
would suggest that Brian seaworth could
figure it
out and
and so I think I understand
representative avalani question so you
know if the question is what language
can be put into the statute so that a
hearing cannot possibly happen one I
would have to give some thought to that
but it is a fair point that
representative sewor raises if there is
a statutory provision that is affording
an option or a right or protection ction
or something of that nature and someone
is alleging through the adjudicative
form I I think this wasn't complied with
and there's a recourse for me and I I
want to have a full and fair
administrative hearing uh on that
recourse and be heard on it absent and
again there are you know preliminary we
call them motions but it doesn't have to
be drafted by an attorney honestly a lot
of wage claims are handled by both
employers and employees on a pray basis
meaning they're not represented um it
can be done via email it can be done in
letter uh something in writing the step
one threshold really is did you assert
enough for us to say we have the ability
to look at it and you're articulating
enough uh of a of a articulable dispute
under the area you're pointing to for us
to get it scheduled because if you come
to the department and you're saying and
I'm going to use a very extreme example
I'm upset about disability
discrimination well we don't have
jurisdiction over that we can't schedule
that for you uh if you're asserting I
think there was a violation of the of
275 48 there were illegal deductions I
think I'm owed money that's enough to
say okay you've asserted a colorable
dispute that the department has the
authority to resolve the employer can
come back and we would call it
technically a motion to dismiss but
might say no that's not true attached
fine payroll records they've been paid
everything was on the up and up um
here's the signed authorization that
they said we could do these deductions
whatever it may be um that can be looked
at for okay is this really rising to the
level of dispute that needs to be
scheduled and it may be dispositioned B
based on that preliminary those
preliminary pleadings it may go to a
hearing and the employer gets the
opportunity to fully flesh out the
argument that they're making and they
get a decision for that so I think it is
very difficult to say we're going to
craft language that just bars you from
having a hearing over an articulated
dispute uh under the under the statute
if the question is is there language
that can be encompassed within this
amendment to make it easier for
employers to navigate such that when
these scenarios arise they're not having
to sort through by 5611 and I think
that's a you know think that's a fair
question to ask we can certainly take a
look at I think that would take a little
bit of thought in research you you would
want to make certain that any language
that was put forward is not going to
interfere or run a foul of the
requirements that are set forth in
561 period and I'm not an expert in that
area so off the top of my head I I don't
know that I would be able to say that's
doable or not doable I think it would
require some thought um and and a little
bit of research but if part of the ask
we can look at that but I don't think
we'd have that one ready by
tomorrow and and i' even
caution assuming that we come up with
something I'd be very nervous about that
so next year
5611 could be radically changed maybe
spouses suddenly the legislators decide
we don't like spouses anymore and they
don't get any money um if we try to
summarize or
simplify the legal process that
exists we risk getting it wrong in our
summary and then we risk creating a
conflict in law if if Chang other side
right no and I think that's also
something that would have to be
considered in trying to put language
together and if I could um one of the
things I understand that representative
Avalon's concerns are the cost for the
employer and I think that that's an
extremely reasonable a concern because a
probate lawyer and state lawyer is not
an inexpensive find um but there is a
resource that is free and that's going
to the actual probate court in the
county in which the probate may take
place the clerk's office may have some
resources um they can certainly point
you in the direction of somebody who
maybe will work for a lower fee but
there are options that they can do
because there's a lot of people that
come before them that don't have the the
money to hire an attorney but need to go
through probate so they may have that as
a resource and that's free for the
do at least make the phone
call well well that's always good I know
a lot of us have business attorneys on
retainer for that for those types of
questions or for in you know inquiries
from do Dr or anything like that um
there shouldn't be an additional cost to
the employer to give somebody their last
paycheck that's what I'm looking at
they're already having the cost of
providing that employee they you know
having that employee there or take the
cost for payroll services and then
having to an additional cost to figure
out who to pay if there is a demand
shouldn't fall to the employer there
should be some type of protection in
case they do make a wrong payment or
there is a wrong turn somewhere that the
do Department La is not going to come
back and say well you paid the wrong
person under this but I paid it under
561 to make sure that there's no wage
claim further down the road by the
proper person that should have gotten
that money and if I can
add I think this is outside Department
of Labor entirely so again it's back to
when will was here I asked him you know
what happens I'm about to approve
payroll and someone comes running in and
say whoa whoa whoa that that gym's
dead
um according to Will from the probate
end I should not not approve I should
take that check out I should hold the
money and I should start this lengthy
process of finding out what's going to
happen to that estate and who I'm
supposed to send the check
to and that's not a Department of Labor
issue and it is because where is it in
law that we can stop we have to stop
payment because not in Department of
Labor Law
275 and that's why we can't fix fix it
in
275 and and that's also and and we
speculate on this that might be why this
will said maybe that's part of how this
came out is to deal with that issue of
instead of tying up one
paycheck less than $300 for months while
you try engaging your lawyer this whole
time well what am I supposed to do with
this 300 you get this safety value well
I can just turn it over to the the
spouse because this allows me that out
so again you know I won't I I won't turn
away more information and learning more
about this but it seems to me to ask to
solve in labor law an issue
that's really dominated
by other areas of
law is too much is too much to squeeze
out of this section that's that's
my since they didn't pay that
employee and somebody came lied to them
and said they were deceased we heard we
may got a car accident he's in I he's
half dead you shouldn't pay them and
then they come back and now now they
file a wage claim you didn't pay my last
paycheck I was in the hospital follow
doing there's a daily fine and then
there's an interest fine and then
there's a percentage fine I it could
stack up to a
large dollar amount for the employer for
making that judgment I just want to make
sure that the employers are
protected Lena was a master of
scenarios as an employee you have to
look at everything keep in mind one
thing and I think this has been said
before I know that representative
inventin has said it I know that
representative kahill has has repeated
it the Department of Labor does is is we
like to educate we like to assist
employers to remain in compliance we
like to help employees when it's
necessary we help carriers to remain in
compliance that is that is what we would
prefer to do and part of the reason why
civil penalties come into play in any of
these is because it didn't work and so
that's just another another step in how
to help that employer remember for next
time to be in compliance or that carrier
Etc and in the context of the
percentages I think what you were
talking about was liquidated damages
that may be at issue and comes up often
times or is an portion of an asserted
claim as it relates to a wage claim the
standard for liquidated damages and I'm
forgive me I don't have it directly in
front of me so I I might not quote it
correctly um but it's essentially the
the mean and mechanism was there to pay
it and the employer knew they needed to
pay it but essentially did not it's it's
like a willful standard so you know if
an employer makes a mistake based on the
belief that they are operating as they
should be or in accordance with the law
and it was not a willful intentional I
had the means and mechanisms to pay the
money was in the accounts I could have
paid the wages I didn't pay the wages
um and um I was under you know knew that
I needed to pay the wages I was aware I
had an obligation to page the wages and
I simply didn't that's where liquidated
damages is going that's an employee is
going to have um a better claim for for
liquidated damages so those are all
factors that would be looked at in the
coarser context of a wage claim so in
the scenario we thought the person had
passed uh we thought we were doing the
right thing as it related to the inter
you know to to probate and count was
frozen or whatever other factors led
into the employer saying I did not pay
on time and the employees asserting that
they want liquidated damages and it's
the I get the percentage wrong 10% or
the full or the full amount of the wages
whichever is higher might be wrong on
the on the percentage those are all
factors that would be looked at in
determining whether or not the employee
had met their burden to demonstrate they
actually are entitled to the liquidated
damages and again it's not a punitive
it's not punitive in the sense that the
employer made a mistake it's not a
mistakes were made here's the punishment
you're you're now being hammered with
liquidated damages it's for those
willful intentional
actions Mr chairman we uh Don and I have
been meeting at three o' so I just all
right so I think in the interest of time
um we have we have the question you can
answer quickly and then if you have more
information on the other ones um we have
plenty of time to receive that as well
so I
will attempt to make the motion see if
it's seconded um that this subcommittee
recommend ought to pass as originally
filed I'll second
okay and all those in favor by right and
you oppos oh you're in favor too all
right so so that's it um so next time
when we meet on Executive this we'll
just say something about what the
change when we receive new information
um I will make sure that all members of
the subcommittee receive it and if um
there is discussion to be had about
changes I'll okay discuss that offline
and perhaps prepare an amendment thank
you all right thank you everyone thank
you for having us today I appreciate all
the all the help I don't know if you
pleasure you expected to be on the hot
seat for what almost two hours our goal
was to be available if you needed us
that's and we're always happy to be
available if you need us so thank you
you got the right to work I'm reading it
is did you see the other one Brian other
email
they were listening to
us who who
they Chris
the who's the woman at legislative
Services Kristen Kristen that Jamie
reports
to report got two two different roles
she just she sent you and I an email I
think I did see that and that's what I
responded to with oh that this is this
one